All of the people who are like so psyched to say, um, well, the
left has Zora Mamani, so like why why is it that big a problem
if we have Fentes? Dude, every one of those people needs to be
first on the wall. Okay, if the lefties do win, please just tell
me before I go, those people will go, okay? If I have to go,
if I have to face the wall, those people face the wall before
me.
But I do want to keep up on this and I Ezra Klein posted this
video. Tucker Carlson, Nick Fentes, and the rights griper problem.
Now, the person I've seen best characterizing this online is
Richard Hania. Think he's got some minor things wrong. Discussed
it a couple times, but he's probably the person with like the
best understanding of this phenomenon so far. Ezra Klein, I'm
not sure if he'll have a good read on it. I think I feel like
Ezra Klein's pretty good at identifying good ideas to take. You
could say that, Puggyups.
We'll see. We'll see if he's got anything here. fortune or just
being a normal person. You had not heard of Nick Fuentes until
this month. Chances are you've heard of him now. >> Nick
Fuentes is odious and despicable. >> He's what I would
call a racist racist. He's just this troll. >> Nick Fentes
has said a long list of very vile things. >> Big time.
He's a a booger eating white supremacist Holocaust denier.
>> What was that Trump take?
Oh, you mean the one about Trump blowing Bill Clinton? What did
he say? Oh, he's always known he was gay cuz the YMCA thing.
I'm telling you, Trump's been displaying his gizzy technique
for like so long. He was showing off what he did at those parties.
Okay.
Trump's always been a child at heart. So, when it came to the
Epstein parties, he was on the uh he was on the receiving end.
All right. He showed off his double fisting technique all the
time. The dick off directly into his own face.
You guys know what I'm talking about, right?
Hold on. Trump YMCA
dance. He just he literally like jerks the [__] off
into his face every time.
>> Doesn't Destiny do that, too? Oh, we're seeing a lot
of comparisons. Okay. Yes. Destiny runs a cult. Trump runs a
cult. They both suck dick. Okay. Of their political rivals,
some would say. Unverified rumors.
[laughter] both have unverified rumors of sucking the dick of
their political rivals. Okay, it's the comparisons
abound.
>> One more time.
>> That's a bad one. Okay, >> that's a real bad one.
Holy [__]
>> I think his mouth was open here. We need the picture
from the other side. I think his mouth was open, dude. Oh boy.
Not
>> Not good. Not good. Not good. Oh, yeah. LG. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I was saying he uh he participated cuz he's a child at
heart. Okay. Participated. >> The reason everybody's talking
about Fuentes is Tucker Carlson, who is arguably at this point
the most significant media figure on the American right, hosted
Fuentes, a person he has feuded with in the past, for a very
friendly 2-hour chat. >> I wanted to meet you. I've heard
about you. M I've heard about you >> about the problem
of Israel about the problem of American Jews and whether or not
they fit in this country or their loyalties are elsewhere. >> If
you're China first, you should live in China. If you're Mexico
first, you should live in Mexico. If you're Israel first, maybe
you should go live in >> It was the kind of conversation
you would not have heard among mainstream figures on the American
right in recent decades. What we are watching is a very old strain
of the right vying for control of its future. This right goes
back to Pat Buchanan. It goes back to Charles Lindberg. The idea
that the right should be an ethnationalist coalition which doesn't
have room for immigrants very much does not have
fundamental misunderstanding. It's like about branding, right?
It's it's like it's we'll see how he goes here. This is like
a bad direction to take it at first. You can take it in this
direction, but then you have to acknowledge that it's like a
multithnic coalition,
right? that this looks like a after school special. You got somebody
of every race, of every gender. They're all participating. You
have to you have to address that and talk about how that happens.
How you can have a white nationalist movement that's more diverse
than the Huffington Post writer room.
>> Have room maybe for that is
really not comfortable with anyone who's not what they call a
heritage American. >> We do need to be Christian. We do
on some level need to be pro-white. Not to the exclusion of everybody
else, but recognizing that white people have special heritage
here as Americans. >> This has been a logic and an ideology
that Trump has broken into the >> That's what we're all
about. America
>> and that is now following itself to its full expression.
If you buy into this, well, it has a place it goes. And now we
are seeing more figures on the American right truly going there.
To talk about it, I want to bring on John Gans. Gans is sort
of hard to describe. is a I think he's become a popular political
theorist and historian. He writes the great substack unpopular
front. He wrote the book when the clock broke which is about
the politics of the 1990s and Patan and David Dugan how they
prefigure Trump. But he's somebody who has been tracking these
ideas and the way they are taking hold on the right and where
they come from in our country very very closely. So I want to
hear what he thought now that they were breaking this far out
into the open. As always my email esar clenchow ny times.com.
>> Wait, who does he talk to for this? >> John Gans.
Welcome back to the show. Thanks so much for having me.
He said junk fans. God damn it. >> So, let's say that blessedly
you've never heard of who Nick Fuentes is. Maybe you've just
heard of him in the last few weeks, >> Who is Nick Fuentes?
>> Nick Fentes, I would say, is the most popular representative
of >> um
bigotry is mine virus.
I mean that's not it just doesn't capture it quite correctly.
It's not like the worst lens to look if you have to look at it
as a lens. I do think it's like a harmful ideology that is a
problem in a lot of ways and I think if you if you don't understand
is probably the the understanding I'd rather you misunderstand
with >> of
America
>> well by his own story he comes from uh a middle class
background in the suburbs of Chicago um he became interested
in political activism um he was a a a a fervent Trump supporter
um and then he ran a foul according to him of some gatekeepers
in the conservative movement, namely Ben Shapiro, who accused
him of anti-semitism when he asked questions about US policy
towards Israel. And then over the years he assembled a following
of other disaffected young men and uh he launched two campaigns
that he called the Groper wars to basically pressure mainstream
conservative figures to move rightward on issues to do with race,
with LGBTQ issues, and with Israel and the subtext being there
to question it. So he's not that subtextoriented compared to
some people in this movement. I mean he'll talk about an admiration
for Adolf Hit. He doesn't just talk about Israel, he talks about
the you know we he was a lot more coded. He had a whole people
say that Fanta has moderated a lot and some in some ways it's
true but I think he has he's had more moderate eras than this
one. like when he was I feel like when he was talking to Destiny
originally when he like went to Miami and stuff, I feel like
he was way more toned down back then than he is right now. I
feel like he was trying to get back into something and he was
like way more toned down until he went to the Kanye stuff. When
he went to the Kanye stuff, it was like a big blow up of like,
oh, we love him actually. But I think he had toned it down quite
a bit around that time. And he is way more toned up now. like
the the pendulum is swung back and he is way more out in the
open now because being anti-semitic is more popular now. Yeah,
but being like overtly racist against black people isn't more
popular. I don't I I don't perceive it to be. I don't perceive
like at least for for black people specifically, I don't think
the the bigotry against them has really gotten
Like I at least that's my perception. I realize that some people
might disagree with that. We have to go a little bit further
than to say something's up with the Zionist or Israel. It's not
Israel. It is the And once again, remember who is responsible
for it all. The
They are responsible for every war in the world. It's not even
debatable at this point. Hitler was a and kind of a pagan. It's
like, well, he was also really cool. >> There's something
there are figures here who it feels like they try to keep a mask
on. >> Yeah. And he doesn't. >> He doesn't. and and
and I think that's a key part of his appeal. Um I think that
his viewers find that refreshing. They find it titillating.
>> I mean to some extent
you could probably argue that Fentes and Quean are like kind
of very very similar people. I could give you like they're I
know that the their Epstein take is like totally overlapped,
right?
like it's it's
oh contrarianism in like a very specifically packaged way to
be like funny and edgy at the same time for the sake of comedy.
It's not like it's not like I'm going to give you this as a real
point. It's like oh I think it's particularly funny to think
of it this way.
Give me a second. Let me find
Where's this Epstein quote? Can we get the Epstein quote? Epstein.
Epstein. Epstein. Epstein. This one. I think it's this one.
dollars.
We have to keep fighting forever. But the name of these people's
game is revenge. And I believe if they ever do except defeat,
they do what they can to enact revenge by destroying our financial
institutions they control and the entire banking system for us
turning on them. Here's the thing. Everybody would say I would
never go. Me Epstein Island, I would never. And it's like, dude,
you're telling me Jeffrey Epstein was probably so cool.
Like he was probably the coldest, coolest guy, you
>> You're telling me the coolest guy you know who knows
everybody says, "Hey,
we're going to go on my private jet to my private island. We
got hot girls." He doesn't tell you how old they are. How lame
would you be? Um, are they 18? Like, who's going to be the nerd
that asks that? You probably would just assume they are. Um,
or [snorts] that it's in international waters, so it doesn't
matter, you know? But like, you're telling me you would automatically
say nope. No. Like you don't know what's going on to all everybody
knew was that he was the coolest guy in town.
The coolest guy in town says, "Hey, I'm rich. Private island,
private jet, hot girls all week. Let's go. Great food. You're
telling me you'd be like, "Are they
Jeffrey? Are they all 18 now? You're telling me you would be
the nerd that would ask that? You have the balls to say that?"
Nick is like describing something that everybody everybody get
offended by this and then it's like dude people do this all the
time. I think I told the story about how I almost died at a bachelor
party, right? Like we got drunk, we went on like this long swim
with like coolers and stuff that like none of us could really
make that well. It was very obvious we couldn't make this swim.
And like while we were sober, while we were like sober, middle
of the day, we we swam out to this place. It's probably like
a 400 500 maybe 600 meter swim. and we got plastered out in this
area and then a storm started rolling in and we're all drunk.
We're like whatever, we'll swim back
and there's like lightning coming down and we're all like we're
all like wasted and trying to swim across this like long swim
in choppy water in a storm and I I went back cuz I didn't want
to be the who's like, "No, I have to walk around." I just wasn't
going to be that. Okay. And I think like 90% of the other people
there also weren't going to be that [__] And then
10% were like lifetime lifeguards. Like they they had taken swimming
lessons all their life and then they lifeguarded until they got
out of university and went to med school. So So like there were
people who were totally qualified to make that swim and people
who were totally unqualified to make that swim. And I wasn't
going to be the who walked cuz it was uh it was basically this
massive loop around or you could swim between these two points,
And so I swam and I was pretty sure I was going to die at some
point. Like I I literally we were like driving back to the where
we had where we're staying for the bachelor party and just nobody
was talking. We just all like staring out the windows just like
yeah that was that was very close to it. That was very very close
to it. We had like two sober people who were driving by the way.
It was fine. It was through the mountains. You wouldn't want
to be drunk driving through there. But yeah I just remember dude
it was like the worst idea I'd ever had in my entire life. Okay.
It was the it was the worst. But anyway, that's like I just didn't
want to be the lame guy who's going to be like that doesn't seem
very safe. Um, should we really swim and then drink alcohol over
there uh at that big water slide thing that goes out into the
middle of the lake? Should we really do that? Yeah, I wasn't
going to do that.
So, that's all I'm >> Honestly, that just sounds kind of
gay to be honest with you. >> It would have been gay. Yes,
exactly. Would have been gay to be that guy who's like, you know
what? I don't think we can actually I don't think we can do that.
Could you imagine you're like take Epstein out of it for just
a second. What if it was exactly like with minors? Yeah, but
dude, I'm sorry. They don't get you. Do you think the pitch from
Jeffrey Epste is do you want to go to my private island where
you can kids or do you think the pitch was like you want to come
to my island where we have crazy
Like obviously if it's a blackmail network that's what they're
doing, right? What Nick is describing. Not like do you want to
come to my island and little kids?
I don't think so. It's like someone you knew in real life and
he's like, "Dude, we got girls. We're going to a party. It's
going to be great." And you're like, "Wait a second."
Pull them aside. Can I see their ID? Like, no one would say that.
So, you could see, but look, but this is how this is how he entrapped
people cuz this is how people are.
Now, fortunately for me, I'm an incel. I don't get invited anywhere.
You know, even my friends don't invite me to They don't invite
me to their parties. You know, nobody invites me to anything
>> and I'm a party pooper. I don't drink. >> It's
so gay. It's so gay to do this. Okay, this like so irrelevant
coded right here.
I don't I believe that you were an insult at some point. Okay,
but at some point you you lose the ability when you have like
a thousand different Tik Toks of like hot women just totally
throwing themselves at you, you don't get to call yourself an
incel anymore. Okay, you could say sell. You can say volel, but
you don't get to say incel
when you have on the record like thousands of women just being
like, I you shut up. Shut the [__] up, you lying
piece of [__] You're just lying. You're literally
lying. Stop lying.
You know, I don't uh sleep around.
I don't even, as a matter of fact, I don't even sleep. I'm awake
all night.
So, you know, that's why you're lucky. People say, "When are
you going to, you know, get when are you going to get mad? First
of all, I'm an incel. Second of all, you want to see me on Epstein
Island?" Like, that's how it starts.
That's how it starts. That's true. Actually, that's true. No
men going to Epstein's Island. Okay. That's never happened. No
man has ever been blackmailed with privately with like secretly
recorded tapes. Okay? It's just never happened before.
Ever. And then Joel Greenberg. If if Trump were a Russia would
be a smoking crater right now, okay, is all I need to is all
you need to know.
Is like setting it up at a hotel room and you don't even know
where you where you are, what you're doing. So,
I don't know. If Epstein invited me, I would certainly consider
it. You're telling me you wouldn't. I would certainly think about
it, but in the end, I think I would say no.
I think ultimately I would uh that would
>> Wow.
I can't even remember why I pulled that pull. Oh, right. So,
they're talking about um Oh, they were talking about how he's
like coded in his views.
Oh, I feel like there's going to be so much so many misunderstandings
here. >> He was also really cool. >> There's something
there are figures
>> Well, he was also
>> really cool. >> Sorry. That was what sparked it
for me was Nick was talking about there, but he also did just
did the same thing with >> Something
there are figures here who it feels like they try to keep a mask
on. >> And he doesn't. >> He doesn't. And and and
I think that's a key part of his appeal. Um I think that his
viewers find that refreshing. They find it titillating. Um and
[music] they find it to be reflective of their >> You mentioned
the Griers. Yeah. >> What's a grier? >> Well, this
let me let me tell you a story of how I became I learned what
gropers are. I was writing a piece for the new >> he he
wrote some pro-Zionist piece and a whole bunch of people put
pictures of him in his own like replies and said
learned about gropers. I I just listen that's a guess that was
me just spitballing pondering the I feel like >> the republic
about 5 years ago about the right and I was learning about what
were young people on the right like what were they thinking about
how do they respond to Trump and what was the future of conservative
media and elites in the Trump era [snorts] >> in the course
of this I kind of uh befriended some young right-wing guys >> and
they kept on talking about gropers
>> and I didn't really know what it was and then I realized
that they were kind of a subculture of a of online of trolls
kind of marginal figures and they had often as their avy or their
avatar profile picture this this kind of grotesque uh code that
looked like Pepe the frog. Uh and it's my understanding that
this subculture is larger than Nick Fuentes and not necessarily
under his control or direction, but that
that's just totally wrong. What?
What? That's like
dude that that's like an insane thing to say. I'm sorry. That's
an insane thing to say. Name somebody who's left that subculture
and like blown up. What? >> He uh speaks for them. He attempts
to speak for them and to unite them into a sort of political
force. But what do the the gorers believe? I mean, this is a
>> sorry or name somebody who's disavowed Nick and stayed
in that subculture and
memeheavy
online. >> Okay. Ethan Ralph was way bigger than them when
he joined and kind of [__] around with them. Ethan
Ralph doesn't count. Ethan Ralph was a guy before he ever [__]
around with any gropers.
>> Also, Ethan Ralph's like a force of nature that cannot
be cannot be destroyed. He doesn't count. Okay, he is a total
He is a super mutant. Okay, we do not count Ethan Ralph. >> Subculture
that is endlessly dancing on the edge of oh, aren't we just joking?
>> And so pinning it down can be a little bit like trying
to pin smoke, >> Because you focus in on a a view and me
it's like, oh, you have no sense of >> Yeah. But it's a
classic. First you're making jokes about the gas chambers, then
you're thinking about sending your enemies to them. >> Yeah.
I think it's it's a little difficult to for people to understand
because we're accustomed to thinking of, you know, politics.
>> Uh guys, we are six subs. We'll do five. Even five or
six subs away from another hour on the stream. We finish this
whole video. Up to you guys. If we don't get another hour, I'll
probably get somewhere near halfway. >> Uh coming from
ideas, coming from intellectuals, elites, media figures that
that disseminate ideas. And this kind of goes in the other direction.
It bubbles up from message boards. It bubbles up from memes,
uh, jokes, ironic, playfulness.
Um, but basically the the the text, not the subtext of all of
them, is kind of a a constant barrage of propaganda that's anti-semitic,
racist, misogynistic, homophobic, you name it. And also a lot
of content that is conspiratorial, obviously, that that that
sees shadowy actors running the government, and is also uh deeply
dissatisfied
with the state of America and the prospects it has for people
like them. So you write this piece on actually read a couple
pieces on the gripification of the Republican party and you wrote
quote here's the thing to understand every single person under
say the age of 40 on the right is exposed to extremely high levels
of griber content every day in group chats on their social media
timelines in discord chats etc. Corism totally suffuses the cultural
environment of the right >> and this point about the people
under the age of 40 this idea that there is a pretty big difference
in what the 20somes on the right are like and what the you know
the 50somes are like I hear that from right all the time. >> So
for people who do not have texture of that cultural environment
what are you describing what are they seeing what does that culture
environment look and feel like? Well, I mean, just recently there
were a couple of leaks about in political reported one of them
about group chats and and basically, yeah, it's a it's an environment
where there's a lot of sharing of of memes and and jokes and
repetition of of memes and uh lots of uh joking about the Holocaust,
joking about history, joking about, you know, uh blacks and and
and you know, uh making jokes about slavery and it's just a kind
of anarchctic uh indulgence of a very sadistic id that usually
involves, you know, um the humiliation of minorities or women.
>> So a lot of the energy of this and a lot of the way
it will get defended >> is that the right in the you know
late 2010s early 2020s its big enemy was the woke mob cancel
culture the thought police gatekeepers >> and you would
hear this described um as
joking but a provocation about that it
>> yo puffshake thank you for the gifted sub. That's one
one down, four or five to go. Okay, thanks guys. >> Showing
that you can say what the cultural enforcers don't want you to
say. Richard Dani, the sort of dissident right figure and intellectual
describes it as like the based ritual where people on the magarite
get together and keep upping the ante to show that they are not
part of the establishment. They're part of this um counterrevolutionary
uh
>> How do you think about the interplay between whatever
that was? because I take it as there there was a sort of culture
that emerged in response to sensoriousness
and then the movement into actual belief.
Well, yeah, I think that that was a way that people could justify
to themselves what they were seeing on an everyday level and
some people could say to themselves and to others that basically
they were participating in a cultural revolt against this sensorious
this sensorious uh state of affairs that um and that was their
interest which was to tear down those norms and to open a space
of freedom. Freedom to do what is the question. Is it just to
you know say and do racist things? I don't know. Um so I think
it it created a structure in which you know those ideas spread
rapidly even to call them ideas is wrong. These these memes really
uh spread rapidly and made it so people who may have been uncomfortable
with it or may have found it uh at variance with their with the
way they were raised uh to kind of look the other way and say
you know we are in a sense playing around. And the first thing
that does, it seems to me, is you're breaking down an immune
system that people have. >> And and you can't extricate
this, in my view, from Trump. >> If you have any hint left
of
>> there's some um [clears throat] I don't know how to
explain this. There's like kind of like cult dynamics. >> The
way you make a movement like this is you just make it so it's
like it's incredibly intolerant to like a a lot of people. you
get like this cultlike belief going and you can steamroll people
all the way along and as long as you're never addressed and you
work in the background like people and you're funny you will
just keep growing. I think DGG was like this for a long time,
right? Where it was just like a lot funnier, a lot cooler than
other I know it's like weird to say for you guys. A lot funnier,
a lot cooler than a lot of places on the other places on the
internet. A lot of better memes like and it was super intolerant
of like certain kinds of people, right? And the Gropers built
up something similar in the rightwing and they they ran with
that for years and and years and eventually there were no other
things like them on the right wing that were like young and funny
and cool.
On the left wing there's lots of young, funny, cool stuff. It
can go in a lot of different directions. On the right wing, there
was nothing. On the right wing, there was like
there's like the gripers and then everybody else was 40. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Major Dr. Gastley. So, it's it's like
very very different.
And I think they just Yeah. Eventually, like there was no way
in private to resist them. You know what I mean? Like they were
just going to be funnier. They're going to have all the funniest.
And in private, if you're not like joking with those people,
if you don't have that same kind of humor, you're just kind of
like a loser. I don't know. There's like a social dynamic that
happens there. I need to think about it more. There's a way to
have like a certain level of intolerance that that puts people
out but is inclusive in like a bunch of other ways that makes
it easy. Like if you're funny and intolerant of a lot of other
people, Brian isn't fun. No, that Holly Han guy is so gay. He's
unbelievably gay.
Like however gay you might think Fentes is, that Holly Han guy
clearly like touches boys, not even little girls, okay? Like
little boys. >> That attachment to old norms and mores
>> courtesies. Yeah. >> Well, then you can't be a
true Trumpist because he doesn't attach to any of >> And
so you begin like demonstrating a cultural affinity to that kind
of politics of provocation and politics of no rules.
Once you've done that, then you actually don't have that immune
system anymore. You're breaking down the immune system that was
supposed to protect against people like Donald Trump himself.
>> Absolutely. I think your point about Trump being the
the originator
thank you so much for the 10 10 gifties. Holy [__]
Thank you so much. That's another hour on the stream. Let's go.
Okay, that's uh that puts us up to the 40 and then we are going
to have
Oh, where are we at? 13 is 65. Yeah, 65.
Call it an even 70. No, we'll call it
What it is, >> we got
28 on the next hour. 12 $12 away for another hour on the stream.
Okay. Thank you so much, Kirsty. Really appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you. >> um when Trump appears and people seem to
forget this for some reason in 20165
uh there was a lot of talk about the alt-right a term that's
not used very much anymore but these people you know who had
previously been on the fringes of American politics greeted the
arrival of Trump you know basically with rapture
>> ecstatically and they knew that this was their kind
of guy they knew that the things that he said would open a space
for them if he wasn't precisely a perfect vehicle for their politics
it was a real big breakthrough so you have you know these people
crawling out of the woodwork you have Richard Spencer um you
have the the Charlottesville
uh riots and then there is kind of a backlash and those people
seem to sort of get pushed out. There's not that much talk about
all nationalism, the alt-right anymore. Um and Trump also doesn't
really seem to be adopting uh some of their preferences in foreign
policy and also not you know he makes some very tasteless remarks
about but not an ideological anti-semitism that they would want
him to do. Um, so this thing kind of goes on the back burner,
but it's very much diffusing the culture of young right-wingers
who are not, you know, they're in the intermediate and lower
ranks of the various, you know, bureaucracies, the various >> um,
I think he's like almost hitting on it. I do think,
man, there was something going on with the alt-right and I was
maybe not paying enough attention to know for sure when the I
feel like and I I always remember it this way and I never know
cuz I was like on 4chan in like edgy internet spaces at the time
like in 2015 2016 2014 15 16 and I don't remember the alt-right
being like explicitly anti-semitic. It was more like the um
like the playful racism. It was like it was really
like the anti-Gamergate type people, right? Like the the the
racism was more of like um
it was not it was not quite the same. Yeah, I know you're going
to say what I I don't remember it being like overtly about anti-semitism.
There was there was like racism, there was sexism. It seemed
like a counterculture thing at the time. See, people say that
I feel like the alt-right started as an internet movement on
like 4chan and Richard Spencer Richard Spencer just was like,
I'm actually going to take that name. That's like my name now.
And I don't think he really represented the the movement like
the the decentralized movement that was forming that was using
that name.
I think he just like sniped it. It was like I'm going to call
it this. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There was like a bunch of other things
kind of adjacent to this. And then I think Spencer like straight
up snanked this and was like, "We're anti-Semitic." Actually,
I I seriously thought at the time, or not at the time, maybe
two or three years later, I was like I looked back on I was like,
"Oh, I wonder if this was um
I almost wondered if it was like one of those like an actual
infiltration moment where they like took that label and they
like tried to rejig it to make it useful for the election." You
remember when Hillary did her whole bit about the alt-right?
I don't know. It was uh [__] It was weird, dude.
It was weird. But I don't now I don't remember it that well.
I can't remember like
how it moved around or the timeline exactly. It might have just
been that I was in spaces that talked about the alt-right and
they didn't like explicitly mentioned Spencer or something.
I don't know. I don't know. Hard to hard to specify now like
way later.
But this guy's talking a lot about the alt-right and I feel like
that wasn't the core of the movement. It's realistically I hate
to do the Brianna Woo thing. It's realistically that whole like
I reject being like a nice normal guy people, the Gamergate people,
the the make tow people, the incelss, red pillars, like there's
this this like counterculture movement that's just like you you
for telling me what I should be I should be nice to everybody
>> staffs of of conservative institutions.
Um and yeah, it never really fully goes away. But then something
else happens, which is that as weak as the gatekeepers are in
this modern era, there are still people with keys to various
gates. And by the end of Trump's first term, Trump is banned
on most of the major social media platforms. Certainly, a lot
of these figures are banned on them. And as Trump makes his return,
and then very specifically when Elon Musk buys Twitter, renames
it X, takes off functionally all of the guard rails,
then the ability of all this to flood into the the conservative
nervous system really changes. I want you to watch a clip from
Tucker Carlson here that I think is interesting.
>> Unfortunately for the Guardians of the old system, the
old Republican party, people have been allowed to describe it
accurately, mostly because Elon Musk opened up X. And you know
when you do that you get all kinds of filth and nonsense and
lies but you also get some truth actually quite a bit of truth.
And one of the main things that people are telling the truth
about that they didn't tell the truth about before is >> Israel
right it's got to be Israel >> that foreign policy really
doesn't have much to do with what's good for the United States.
And once those words have been uttered they can't be taken back.
>> So Carlson here is talking about Israel. I maybe he's
not entirely talking about Israel, but that dynamic he's describing
that Musk taking over
is a hinge point seems true to me. Does it track for you? Absolutely.
I mean, all of these these figures reemerged when they they they
had been pushed out and they create a media ecosystem
uh that that uh is is sused with these ideas. So, first of all,
yeah, there is a um you know, a lot of people online are looking
for information. They're looking to understand an extremely complicated
world. They encounter, you know, and they have a sense that perhaps
the the establishment views are either misin misinforming them
or are just flat out boring. Um, and then they discover, you
know, a narrative about things that's more appealing, uh, simplifying,
seems persuasive, exciting, >> exciting, and also it cannot
be discounted that in particular is extremely entertaining. Um,
and they, yeah, gravitate towards these crackpot ideas. Look,
you know, we, the United States, its support of
Israel, um, is a perfectly legitimate topic to dispute and and
to to have differing views about and to criticize. And more and
more people are coming around to that position. They saw what
was happening in Gaza and they were deeply upset by it. >> And
they look for commentary and opinion on that, right? >> And
the commentary and opinion on that that they get is not, you
know, what the New York Times is saying or what the New York
are saying or even, you know, leftwing outlets like The Nation
or something like that. They get Nick Fuentes, they get Candace
Owens, they get all these kind of crackpot views about it, which
take that discussion about real world issues and a mixture of
rational discussion and um you know commentary that's actually
somewhat sophisticated. I would say I I don't know if this is
true. I feel like a lot of people do get a decent amount of information
on Israel.
Like I don't believe that you could have Nick Fentes and Candace
Owens be as popular as they are and talk about Israel and if
Israel wasn't doing anything wrong that those narratives stick.
I don't believe it. I don't I don't believe it's that far gone
yet. It's like pretty far gone, but I don't think it's like that.
Like he's saying, "Oh, all you get is this crackpot stuff." It's
like, dude, you can have a very well-informed non-conspiracy
based understanding of what's going on in Israel and you can
think Israel is like monstrous.
>> Fantasy's case and then channel that into propaganda
for for anti-semitism. And I think it's important to realize
um again back to your question about ideas and the and the diffusion
of ideas that you know not everyone is aware that they're being
propagandized, right? >> No. What the is that like dislike
ratio? Um people hate Ezra Klein. Pretty much everybody except
liberals hates Ezra Klein. So >> they are in an information
environment where this is what they see and it becomes normal,
right? And in a sense they get captured. They are in you know
we people love to talk about the liberal bubble, liberal elite
bubble. There is a an equivalent bubble of of the hard right.
So yeah that that brings this kind of deformed version of the
public sphere uh that must allow to happen and I think one could
argue intentionally. I want to get it a bit of backstory here
before we get into the Tucker Carlson Nick Fuentes interview
because this is not the first time Nick Fuentes has broken through
to the mainstream of
>> Yeah. There's a very famous dinner. >> At Mara
Lago, I believe >> where Donald Trump is dining with Kanye
West noted anti-semite >> and Kanye brings Nick Fentes.
>> At the time Trump looks like the past of the party.
People think, you know, he's like on his way out. It's going
to be Ronda Santis in 2024 or someone like >> Yeah. And
I think they also buy the idea which Trump says afterwards and
I take is even plausible that he doesn't really know who Nick
Wendy is. I think people buy with Trump that he talks to a lot
of people. And one reason I think this is breaking through in
the way it is is twofold.
You don't have any of that deniability on Carlson's side. >> And
now everybody understands that the future of Trumpism is up for
grabs. How would you describe the role Tucker Carlson plays on
the right now? I I think that he strives to be a person of great
influence in directing the policy staffing
um you know messaging of the Republican party and to a certain
extent he is you know he has deep ties to to people in the administration
uh >> help JD Vance named vice president >> absolutely
and uh you know he's a >> the intel community >> he's
a figure I would I would say it is more helpful to interpret
him as a >> I agree I think that he basically
um
the direction of the Republican party and remade his entire image
himself
uh to to fit in with it and um he has been very smart about that
and he realized you know the old institutions ain't what they
used to be does it really matter that he's on Fox anymore apparently
not very much you know so his his creation of a new persona um
really is the story of the transformation of the Republican party
so at this point how would you describe what Tucker Carlson's
politics are like what what poll of right-wing ideology does
he seem to hue to and >> Uh he he represents a tradition
that's sometimes called isolationist which views um you know
America's entanglement uh with foreign alliances and interventions
in in in other countries to not necessarily be in our interest.
Um not necessarily dovish but uh definitely the United States
should apply force when it wants when it needs to in his own
very direct self-interest. Um I believe that he he calls himself
a Christian. I believe he's a represents a Christian nationalism
which is non-Zionist or anti-inist. Um again there are some roots
in that and the old right that that goes back for the pre-war.
Um he is a very hostile to immigration. Um he seems to have a
very >> I did not attract much but the tea party when it
was big. No I mean a little bit not a lot >> strong sense
of white ethnic identity and thinks that it believes that you
know uh it's a problem for the country if there are too many
non-white >> Forgive me if I'm misremembering this. Didn't
you do an interview with like the son of a Ku Klux Clan member?
>> Oh my god. I'm I'm so glad you brought that up. So,
I was working on a piece in 2020 about the conservative movement
and Tucker was a big part of it and his is his his kind of transformation
into a populist into a right-wing populist. And uh I got a remarkable
quote from someone who was the child of of Don Black, a Ku Klux
Clan leader and a and and a a big figure in the white nationalist
movement. Um,
the person I got the cold front, just to be clear, left the movement
and was highly critical of it. But here's what they told me.
From the perspective of my family, Tucker's making the same points
they've been trying to make their entire lives, but much better.
He's found a wider audience and the ideal method of expression
for many of the same ideas. My father's a little baffled still
that it's Tucker Carlson, sometimes someone who he always never
liked because he saw him as a shill for the Bush administration
and the Iraq war that's bringing white nationalist ideas to the
Fox audience. I got this quote. I'm I'm I'm not a very experienced
journalist at the time. This is the beginning of my career. I
got this quote and I brought this to my other sources for the
story who were young people on the right. And I thought I had
some >> Okay, I'm going to be right back. I'm listening
still. I'll be right back. I just got to use the bathroom real
quick. >> I think this positive. I thought I had something
that showed uh Tucker Carlson's playing around with things that
you really shouldn't. Um that he's he's moving in a very disturbing
direction. They shrugged. [music] They didn't care.
And I I found that to be shocking and disturbing. And I think
that anecdote says a lot. >> I also think and I think this
is very important to understand Tucker and the role he plays
is he understands something Trump understands but not everybody
does which is the modern right even more than the modern left
is driven by attention. >> Trump has remade it around an
attentional economy. >> And there isn't somebody behind
a Trump as good at attention as Trump is. JD Vance certainly
isn't.
>> You don't have to be the president to be the leader
of MAGA. that it is very plausible to me that you would have
a JD Vance nomination, but actually the next leader of MAGA is
Tucker Carlson. That I think what Tucker Carlson is trying to
be is the authentic voice of MAGA who because he doesn't have
to do all the political coalition work, >> He can be pure
>> than someone like JD Vance, who I think fundamentally
agrees with Carlson at this point. >> But has to maintain,
you know, or attempt to maintain, you know, viability in Michigan.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. Here's the thing. Uh yeah, I think
Carlson views himself in that role for sure. You know, Tucker
Carlson was sort of the median, I would say, not exact conservative
Republican to a certain degree. You know, kind of uh towed the
party line on most issues, Iraq, um you know, all this kind of
stuff. Uh American foreign policy.
He was also trying to present himself as a kind of reasonable
time, you know, libertarian rich kid. >> Yeah, there's
that, too. And it's interesting he takes that bow tie off. You
know, there there's a degree that there's costume changes here.
You know, he takes a bow tie off. He he now has this more folksy
look, uh, check shirts and so on and so forth in this cabin,
etc., etc. You know, he's he's cultivating an image of himself
as down to earth and folksy and not part of the establishment.
And it's, you know, it's it's hard to take when you realize he's
the product of it. >> I uh I just totally lied and missed
the past like 60 seconds. So, my bad. I'm going to I'm going
to roll it back. I'm so sorry that I did that to you guys. Okay,
that's my bad. >> He can be pure >> than someone
like JD Vance, who I think fundamentally agrees with Carlson
at this point. Yeah. but has to maintain, you know, or attempt
to maintain, you know, viability in Michigan. >> Yeah,
absolutely. Here's the thing. Uh, yeah, I think Carlson views
himself in that role for sure. You know, Tucker Carlson was sort
of the median, I would say, not exact conservative Republican
to a certain degree. You know, kind of, uh, towed the party line
on most issues, Iraq, um, you know, all this kind of stuff, uh,
American for MSNBC. He was on MSNBC. He was also tried to present
himself as a kind of reasonable. >> He's like a good time,
you know, libertarian rich kid. >> Yeah, there's that,
too. And it's interesting, he takes that bow tie off. You know,
there there's a degree that there's costume changes here. You
know, he takes a bie off, he now has this more folksy look, uh,
check shirts and so on and so forth in this cabin, etc., etc.,
you know, he's he's cultivating an image of himself as down to
earth and folksy and not art of the establishment. And it's,
you know, it's hard to take when you realize he's the product
of it. Um, and then but but there's something important to understand
about Tucker Carlson's turn, I think, to anti-semitism in particular,
right? I believe that, you know, anti-semitism functions as an
>> is that just like a foregone conclusion now that Tucker
Carlson's anti-semitic?
>> Where's the Where's the anti-semitism? What I I just
want to know what like statements are literally being called
anti-semitic from him.
Cuz I get why people like kind of lean in that direction, but
other than the other than the funeral comment, I've got nothing
that's like overtly anti-semitic from him. epoxy for elites that
don't really want social changes that would affect their prominence
and in fact want to shore up their prominence and need mass support
and need a target uh and need a story about um economic dispossession,
a world that doesn't seem to make sense uh that serves their
interests. You see this in a lot of different places. You see
it in Russia, you know, the the Tsarist regime kind of invented
anti-semitism for this purpose. The the protocols of elders of
Zion are created in this regime of that's feeling uh the pressure
of a of a mass population that's becoming dissatisfied with it
creates anti-semitism, you know, as a as a way to to to rechan
that >> Wait, did they they created
What why did uh why did Hrien raise uh
Jerusalem to the ground? Why did he like
why did he destroy all of Judea?
I I would have thought if you want to go with somebody who invented
anti-semitism, you go with like the pharaoh. You go with like
Hadrien.
That's crazy to say it was Zarus Russia. >> You see this
in France uh where you have an aristocracy and a clergy that
is kind of put >> Wait, was that Hrien? Yeah, Hrien ended
>> Push into old institutions sees its prominence in the
society losing out. it's sort of losing its its world and then
it needs to find a mass politics, a way to attack its enemies
and anti-semitism becomes very useful for that. So anti-semitism
always works to create a kind of coalition. There's a street
gutter crackpot anti-semitism and then you have what you could
call more respectable anti-semites. Let's say um Charles Lindberg,
right? A person who was highly respected, respectable >> This
is the guy that I think people argue Fentes modeled himself after.
>> you know. >> Oh [__] Did I just get
a huge donation that I missed that I like actually just totally
missed? [__] Hold on. >> A great hero to many
Americans. Um, but found the
racial view of the world and found anti-Semitic ideas persuasive.
Henry >> Henry Ford. Um, so you had these respectable anti-semites
and crackbot anti-semites and the
>> they're coming together I would say is this is the creation
of an actual anti-semitic politics, right? And this interview
between Fuentes and Carlson is this almost almost textbook. You
have the anti-semitism of the gutter fuentes and you have the
anti-semitism of a declining aristocracy. Right? Tucker is this
kind of comes from this crappy background. Father was an ambassador.
>> I don't what is going on. Wait,
hold on. Did he somehow prove Tucker was anti-Semitic in the
time where I was gone? like you. So the best argument for Tucker
being anti-Semitic is maybe not like maybe the idea that he platform
Fuentes at all. I don't It's like so nebulous to try to prove
this that Tucker is just like out and out
I don't know where that's coming from.
Why is he Why is he just saying that? That like that's a given
and Ezra isn't asking any questions. >> Uh stepmother's,
you know, Swanson. Um, and you know, sees an America that's not
the way he wants it to be, that's declining, that that doesn't
look the way he looks like, that has norms that he doesn't look,
you know, doesn't share. And you have Fuentes who comes from,
you know, he he didn't go to college, he dropped out of college,
comes from a modest background. He he is dripping with resentment
to a world that he feels uh doesn't have a place for >> A
self-described crowd incel. >> Yeah. He and and also very
interesting that he does not try to hide it or pretend that he
is not, you know, socially maladjusted in some way. And that
that lends him authenticity and makes people gravitate towards
it. So yeah, that is the most perfect in that interview in that
moment the most perfect encapsulation of anti-semitic politics
declining aristocracy uh held down uh dissatisfied kind of mob
bringing them together and you have a kind of coalition itself.
>> Let's get into that interview. I want to play a clip
for you that almost felt to me like the heart of it. >> Israel
is unlike every other country in the sense that because the people
are in a diaspora all over the world. There are significant numbers
of Jews in Europe but also in the United States and because of
their unique heritage and story which is that they're a stateless
people. They're unassimmilable. They're resist assimilation for
thousands of years. And I think that's a good thing. And I guess
what I'm saying is that if you are a person in America, you're
sort of, and again, it's not because they're born, but it's sort
of a rational self-interest politically to say I'm a minority.
I'm a religious ethnic minority. This is not really my home.
My ancestral home is in Israel. There's like a natural affinity
that have for Israel. And I would say on top of that for the
international community is that they have this international
community across borders extremely organized uh that is putting
the interest of themselves before the interest of their home
country. And there's like there's no other country that has a
similar arrangement like that. No other country has a strong
identity like that. This religious blood and soil conviction
this history of being in the diaspora stateless wandering persecuted.
Um and in particular the historic animosity between the Jew people
and the Europeans. They hate the Romans because the Romans destroyed
the temple. That's why Eric Weinstein goes to the Arch of Titus
and gives it the finger and takes a picture. We don't think like
that as Americans and white people. We don't think about the
Roman Empire in 2,000 years ago. They do. Um and and so I guess
that's really and I don't think that's me saying the
I don't think that's me being hateful. I don't think that's me
being collectivist. I think that's understanding that identity
politics, whether you love it or hate it, whatever you feel about
it, it's a reality that we live in a world of Christians, of
whites and blacks. these >> So I think there there's another
fundamental misunderstanding here, right? As
this Gans guy has spoken, he's like, "Oh yeah, Fent is like the
totally lowbrow anti-semitism."
To me, that strikes as somebody it smacks as someone who's basically
never watched the guy outside of clips,
right?
Like I understand the he he absolutely can be lowbrow anti-semitism.
That's true. But I I don't know why you'd say that's the whole
thing. It's the It's the fusion of the two. He does what Tucker
does basically as well or better than Tucker and he does what
like a lot of other straightup racists do and he can just be
straight up racist, right? And he picks very good at least for
modern culture, for Tik Tok, for clips. He does a good job of
picking when to do
I Why is the mainstream totally ripped and unable to contend
with Fentes?
man, there's a couple different reasons,
they think you can like talk to the guy and actually like argue
the points. He's not really trying to argue stuff. He's not really
trying to He's trying to tell a compelling story that the audience
hears and they'll listen to, right? He's not really arguing with
you. And you could say, "Oh, you're wrong on this. You're wrong
on that." He'll go, "Ah, whatever." And they'll just move on
and keep telling the story. But he's his goal is just to be the
most compelling storyteller. Okay? That's like the goal all the
time. And so it makes it hard to platform him and and contend
with what he's saying in any way that works. >> Mean something
to us and they mean things to each other and we we can't sort
of wish them away. And it feels like white people and Christians
are the only ones that do that. >> There's no question
about that. Your last point for sure. One of the reasons they
do that is because they've been taught to hate themselves of
course since the Second World War.
>> All right. That's what you might call a rich text. >> Yeah,
sure. How do you read it? Well, I mean, you know, he's an extremely
talented rhetoric and communicator and he does a few things.
He presents
um a vocabulary that does not sound shocking to people that uses
words and terminology um that wouldn't frighten people that talks
sounds like a rational
>> The question is how do you counter that? I don't know.
The counter to that was just deplatforming him. Um in a modern
day where people have zero downside for lying, where they can
lie with impunity, where they never have to engage with stuff,
where you can have like these online cults that give you favorability
in every algorithm that exists, right? If you can have a bunch
of people who are willing to smash that like button the second
you post something, that massively advantages you on every platform,
especially when they're like, especially when these platforms
are trying to filter out bot views, bot likes. If you have people
who are naturally congregating around your content and constantly
amplifying it, that gives you an insanely outsized influence.
It's um like something's got to give on one of these fronts or
your cuz a bunch of other people cope themselves into thinking
being correct is like the big deal is like the biggest thing.
It's really just about telling the correct story all of the time
and also having like a cult.
Having a cult can't understate how important just a small cult
is. Okay. >> Politics, rational comment on politics. And
then weaved into this is all of the material of classic anti-semitism.
The are an unassimilable group, self-interested, internationally
organized. Internationally organized very tightly. >> Wait,
hold on. Are an unassimilable
They've not had a state and they've not been assimilated for
like thousands of years. This is fairly unique. There's like
a couple other groups in the Middle East that are like this.
But for Jewish people, they don't really have an area. They're
not even they're barely like significant minorities in a lot
of countries,
right? It's like a totally different population that's like spread
out in this way. Like it's it's very very very different. I he
I want I want him to say where people are wrong cuz he just said
like, "Oh, this is like classic anti-semitism. people are
I like well
it's not wrong to say that people are unassimilable that Romani
people are unassimilable.
It's not wrong to say that. It's like just historically true.
It's not saying they're savages. It's saying they have a culture
that's like insular and doesn't give into other cultures very
easily. Doesn't like accept people from outside. Doesn't allow
people out as easily. Right?
If I said that Amish people or what's the other one? There's
like the Amish and
Oh, what are the They're kind of like the Amish.
Hutterites. Yeah, Hutterites and Menanites. If I said like these
people, Hutterites, Menanites, Amish, if I said they're insular
cultures, nobody disagrees. Nobody disagrees when you say they're
unassimilable. It's like they have cultural practices that make
them unassimilable. There are that are unassimilated. They're
assimilated throughout all of Europe and America.
So, I would say in the modern era, maybe. But the I think assimilation
he's saying that they basically blend into the regular culture.
People have their own culture. They have their own identity that's
outside of the national cultures they're a part of. This is true
in almost every country they're in, right? Like the majority
of people will have a culture that is unique. So when when you
talk about white people existing in that's not just Orthodox
Mara dude. You you just maybe don't understand. It's not even
like a big deal. the majority. Nobody's talking about Orthodox
versus reform. We're saying that the people who go to temple
who are reformed, who aren't like aggressive, those people would
still have like a joint religious because it's an ethno religion,
right? All the groups that resist assimilation, by the way, I
believe are ethnore religions, right? Basically, all of them
all talking to each other and kind of working as one mind. uh
who who don't have their the interest of their of their host
you know at heart of their own interest at heart and are animated
by a deep hostility to the people that surround them to the to
the societies they find themselves hatred towards Christians
towards white people so on so forth >> okay I have to go
through that list again that he was going to do
>> all of the material of classic anti-semitism the are
unassimmable group self-interested internationally >> this
is all what like he's going to say these are all the classics
elements of anti-semitism,
you should contend with whether or not they're true first. Is
he going to say people aren't internationally organized?
Is he going to say that?
That seems like an insane thing to say.
Like a totally insane thing to say. What religions do gypsies
have? I think it's like a vague like I they have I don't think
they like have a religion like an organized religion in the same
way. They have like a set of superstitions
like a pag not pagan belief. Um, it's like a set of superstitions
like Wiccan or something, right?
>> Internationally organized very tightly and all talking
to each other and kind of working as one. >> Not very tightly.
I don't think I don't think he said very tightly there. I think
he said they have a natural affinity for like something like
Israel. And I don't know how you can decline that when aren't
the stats like 89 to 90% support for Israel in people living
outside of Israel. I
>> I would say the part where like the dual loyalty thing
comes in. I'd say that's where it starts to waver. But it's so
weird when he starts he starts correcting at the parts that are
obviously correct. Like why don't you just wait till you get
to the dual loyalty part where oh people have this natural loyalty
to Israel over their host countries or something. Wait for him
to say that before you actually start assigning that belief or
sort before you actually start disagreeing. Don't disagree on
the obviously true parts.
uh who who don't have their the interest of their of their host
you know at heart have their own interests at heart and are animated
by a deep hostility to the people that surround them to the to
the societies that find them hatred towards Christians towards
white people so on so forth that is classic anti-semitism but
he keeps on saying things like you know it's and that's a good
thing or something like that or it's not really I'm not trying
to be hateful you know he he presents it as if he's having a
discussion of politics like any other >> and the the other
move in there in addition to the the obsessed with Romans which
I to say I don't feel very obsessed by >> I kind of like
>> but the the other move in there which you see a lot
on the right and a lot on the white identity right let's call
it >> is look the are just practicing their identity politics
don't we just have to practice ours >> and that final move
>> which is the one where Tucker says well there's no doubt
about that we white Europeans the heritage Americans how to hate
ourselves there's been no uh rational self-interest since World
War
>> that is I think a very fundamental move of Trumpism
that's the bridge >> yeah oft anti-semitism to Trumpism.
This >> Oh, I just want please engage please engage with
why that is wrong. I want I want them to engage with why that's
If you if you refuse to engage with why
with why that you have to say why that's wrong, you can't just
point to these ideas and go that's a Trump idea and I and isn't
it crazy that that's also
You you don't do this. Don't be the caricatures. Don't do it.
Don't do it. Don't do it. Agarite has spent years saying, "Look,
the whole left place identity politics. It's time for white people
to stand up for themselves. You're getting all this anti-white
racism and here it is, right? The the or the danger to that.
If they're going to practice their politics, you have to practice
yours." >> Yeah. Yeah. Precisely. I mean, look, at the
core of the ideology is a social Darwinistic view of the world
divided into almost different species of being who are engaged
in an endless war with each other. And the are particularly important
part of that worldview. um they are the most threatening of these
beings and trying to launder what is a kind of um biological
essentialism about the nature of the political uh through well
normal interest group politics of course you know in America
we have coalitions we have representatives of different ethnic
groups who advocate on each other's behalf well you know you
there's a congressional black caucus you know what's wrong with
that you know why why shouldn't white people do that it is it
is a different kind of politics it's not just like oh they should
be able to practice their own identity politics and they can
kind of uh be integrated through the political process and their
interests are taken care of and balanced with other people's
interests. No, the idea is that this group is impossible to assimilate
and also national.
>> Wait, I I don't think so. I think at least not on Tucker's
side. Tucker's kept saying his principles over and over again.
Israel should be treated like any other country. They shouldn't
have any special privileges. Feels like they have some special
privileges. And I feel like if Israel if if people get to advocate
in their own self-interest as a group, as an identity group,
then white people should get to do the same. That's
that's all it is.
And they they're hopping around it. He said, "Oh, if it was just
like if it was just that that would be fine, but like also people
like what?
They haven't said what's wrong with it, but then they just address
like Fentes's politics and haven't actually talked about Tucker's
the success of the nation, its health is impossible to accomplish
without their expulsion."
This is the view and this is the view that Fuentes continually
hammers on. >> There is a lot here. They That was such
a weird bit right there.
That was so bizarre to me that Ezra says like in Trumpism there's
this thing like oh why can't white people advocate for themselves
which is true and it's like one tell me why that's wrong two
have a sorry one have a coherent argument for that why that's
wrong and then
I guess you can connect it to anti-semitism
or you say you can connect it it's like
I don't know they keep they keep skipping around they don't please
just answer the questions or or say what's
Like I would say if I if I had to answer that, why shouldn't
you have groups advocate for themselves? Well, because there'll
always be like one dominant group or there will likely emerge
a dominant group and if you have if it's a zero sum game between
these ethnicities and they're all advocating with these groups,
eventually it's going to turn
But they've just they just like
they they're they just keep webbing Tucker to Fuentes over and
over again without addressing the fact that Tucker has explicitly
denied believing the things that they're attributing to him and
they're just calling him anti-Semitic.
Where where is the proof? Where is the connection? Where do it
connect it? Find a way to connect it. This guy has basically
said, "Yeah, an old white supremacist basically gave me a quote
that Tucker does a really good job at white supremacy at white
uh like white identity is a really good job at that." And then
Wentz likes Tucker and then Tucker
criticizes Israel and then Tucker like kind of thinks white people
should be able to advocate for
Where is the anti-semitism?
Where have you described anti-semitism? It hasn't been described.
that's tricky to talk about because you're at this endless morass
at the intersection of anti-semitism and Israel.
>> One move I'm seeing from a lot of people on the right
at the moment is why should we be talking about what this, you
know, rumble influencer thinks about the when the left is electing
Zoran Mani, right? When there's been these years of debate about
anti-semitism on the left. I'll say this super clearly. I've
met Zoran Mani, voted for Zoran Mani. I don't think there's anything
anti-mitic about him at all. I think you see in the way he has
been treated and then also what is happening on the right. [laughter]
>> Dude, all of the people who are like so psyched to say
um well the left has Zora Mamani so like why why is it that big
a problem if we have Fentes? Dude, every one of those people
needs to be first in the wall. Okay, if the lefties do win, please
just tell me before I go, those people will go. Okay, if I have
to go, if I have to face the wall, those people face the wall
before me. Just promise me that. Okay, for the love of God, >> a
distinction that is worth understanding, a structural distinction
anti-ionism on the left often pushes towards what I would call
liberalism, a belief that all people should have equal rights,
that there should be universalism. There's a different version
of it if you're more sort of socialist and Marxist, but but the
left tends to push towards a universalism.
>> And a lot of the anger at Israel, which is I think much
of it merited, is the way it portrays universalism for the Palestinians
living under its control. >> Sure. on the right, it's pushing
towards ethnostate politics, >> right? That the the fundamental
argument and a way in which Israel's tried, modern Israel's tried
to create new coalitions is to say, "Hey, we're all ethnostates
here, >> But once you buy into the ethnostate frame, then
the fact >> you can no longer reject
you can no longer reject the other side, right? Or sorry, you
can no longer reject your peers once you've bought into the ethnostate
frame. This is a big thing with people def like defending Israel
is it basically comes down to well I defend Israel because the
Holocaust was a unique thing and I understand why to be sad right
now if you've ever made that argument and then you also make
an argument that's like kind of stupid as well that no maybe
not stupid you can't make that argument and then go well also
Ma was worse than Hassan is worse than Nick Fuentes
you can't do that either the Holocaust was unique or it wasn't
okay and and that's why deserve the ethnicity you have to you
have to figure out your arguments All right. Leavan's such a
midweight loser. He's okay.
I don't I don't hate Ezra Leavant. At least he's doing something
interesting.
At least he's like trying to do something. He's not like just
AFK. I should leave the race to the highest IQ.
>> Loses to Mysto Zoomer. Myst did a lot of work for a
long time. He put a lot of investment in. Okay. >> Choose
as an ethnic other in your society pushes somewhere very different.
Absolutely. Pushes towards ideas of expulsion. Pushes towards
ideas that
Did Mau or whatever wipe out an entire race of people? No. But
he he basically only people of one ethnic group.
So
wasn't his intent to genocide them cuz he was a part of that
ethnic group. But you could say it's like unique in that I guess
they were going after an ethnic group certain ethnic group first
but they killed a lot of groups. the the uh
>> a fifth column within that they are leading your country
to betray its actual interests in order to you know that they
have dual loyalties but but there is this weird thing where it
is there's been a rise of like figures or figures who want to
embrace ethnostate politics I mean you have like yorum hazone
uh you know lives in Jerusalem the founder of noncon going to
the nacon conference which he started saying look you have to
like the to be a national
>> but there's no nobody ever said and I I this is for
my friends nobody ever said that to to be a good naccon, you
had to love Israel. Nobody ever said that to be a good Ncon you
had to love. >> And so the one point of anger I have [laughter]
a lot of people on the right who I think have been playing footsy
with this for a long time is that the
once you embrace the ethnostate concept. This is where that leads.
>> Well, I certainly am of that opinion. I think again,
you know, let's let's take this from another angle. Like the
way you're talking is in terms is a little high brow. in terms
of >> yeah I do I do like this that basically once you've
bought to the idea that your race matters your race is something
you have to advocate on behalf of then it becomes a zero sum
game and then you can't be shocked when people are like oh we
shouldn't support Israel right you can't you can't other Latinos
as illegal immigrants who need to be deported because they're
taking all the jobs and they do all the crime and you can't other
those people and then go wait don't do that don't do that same
thing to people that's up don't do that to people what the
>> you intellectuals like Amazonian. But let's look at
this from the ground up. >> You have a conservative movement
that has embraced, as you said before, an extremely provocative
tone, a tone of of open uh bigotry in certain cases, right? And
basically the deal that the pro-Israel right thought it could
make is we can engage in a good deal of racist uh demagogy. We're
okay with it, especially maybe directed at Muslims, Islam. Um,
[snorts] but the line that we draw is when it when it happens
to to when when it turns into anti-semitism. That is not a consistent
position. That is a that is an extremely self-defeating position.
So when I talk about gripification, I don't mean to say it's
only that people with these extremely specific views about Israel
and are taking over the right. It is more that um there's a general
atmosphere of moral anarchy of uh acceptance of extremely hateful
and and divisive views. So it's not and that creates as as we've
discussed um there there's there's no there's no immune system
there's no barrier to anti-semitism. >> Well that also
goes to the the energy that MAGA Trumpism that the modern right
generates from transgression once you have begun to exhaust the
energy of transgression about how you talk about >> Uh
you know Trump comes down the escalator says they're sending
rapist and murderers over here. There's big outrage. Now being
much more immigrant on the right I mean that's Derek who >> once
you have moved past a bunch of the energy on dancing around racism
right once you have moved you know on traditional gender roles
right
>> this is the boss battle >> of western speech taboss
>> right right >> that and and you have seen this
didn't begin last week or two weeks ago >> you saw Elon
Musk respond to somebody laying down a conspiracy that it's pushing
immigrant voters to take over the country by saying you've really
spoken the truth here you have a lot of the podcast bro faction
this turn more right like Joe Rogan bringing on revisionist historians
>> who you know was Germany really the bad guys in World
War II what kind of you know what what what have we not been
told about that >> and so you sort of bring these two things
together that you want to build an ethnostate
>> and you are ideologically opposed to there being anything
you can't talk about and you make your money and your attention
on these algorithms
and it's almost a hydraulic process towards >> Yeah. The
thing about a kid, [laughter]
>> dude, what? Why? Why? Why would that go for Why would
that be anti-semitism over anything else?
What? What?
I don't
I just don't get why that would target one race just
I don't know why that just seems weird to me. Like, that might
be true. I just can't think of like why that would uniquely target
people.
You would think that would uniquely target like a lot of races
would be fueled a lot of
I wouldn't think it's a hydraulic process towards anti-semitism.
>> What what what have we not been told about that? And
so >> it was it was the ethnostate thing the you would
talk about anything and then being fed by attention algorithms
and stuff. I can see how that's all kinds of transgression gets
like amplified. I can see that. I don't get why the biggest transgression
would be anti-semitism.
I don't I don't get that. That doesn't make any sense to me why
that would be more important, why it even has its own name versus
just being racism.
>> You sort of bring these two things together that you
want to build an
and you are ideologically opposed to there being anything you
can't talk about and you make your money and your attention on
these algorithms and it's almost a hydraulic process towards
>> Yeah. The thing about a kick getting excitement from
it, you know, Sartra said it's amusing to be an anti-semite.
There is something look yeah Mani for example who some people
say is an anti-semite because of his positions on Israel. Um
>> why why would you even know that quote >> he he's
very careful to to say I'm not an anti-semite and to and to express
sensitivity to Jewish concern >> and go to synagogues and
I mean Madani is a liberal. >> Okay. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
But but he also does not uh whatever you think is at the heart
of his politics he does not debate. Right. He is not practicing
a politics that is based on the enjoyment of the harassment uh
and and and getting a rise out of in other words [music] and
fu days absolutely does Tucker does to a more subtle extent can
Owen does and that also attracts people because you know people
who feel powerless are very attracted to it because you know
you you know they're someone you can harass and pick on and it's
part of their strategy to kind of take over the right and their
direction is to do this in a way workplace harassment against
their allies to bait them get them to overreact to unsettle them.
The other thing you mentioned is that the >> I feel like
you're either arguing that control things in a way that is like
unsettling or you're arguing are just actually histrionic who
they'll overreact to everything. I'm not sure which one of those
would be more offensive to people. But are people genetically
histrionic or are they genetically evil and taking over the planet?
I'm not sure which. >> The boos are breaking down because
you know World War II and the Holocaust is a long time ago. >> That's
by the way that's just that's this guy's argument. Okay, that's
not my argument. I'd never say that. That sounds anti-semitic.
>> The generation that that experienced is gone and the
politics that were created out of the consensus that it's that
it created is disappearing. So some of it is just the passage
of time. Again, this is tricky to talk about, but >> you
can't get away here from how much Israel post October 7th, the
the war in and the flattening of Gaza >> has destabilized
politics around this everywhere, right? And again, I think the
way >> it destabilized politics everywhere because suddenly
you could see all the [__] that's going on in Israel,
all the [__] that's going on in Palestine, right?
And you could see it all. And then you'd have politicians who
go, Israel's our most important ally. They're, you know, they're
most moral army in the world. And it's like, you're watching
kids get you're watching kids burn to death. Like most moral
army in the world. Most moral army in the world. ways in which
it has created tensions on the left have gotten most of the attention
for the past couple of years, >> but in fact it's cracking
open the right and and you hear it in this Carlson Fuentes interview.
You hear it in the questions getting asked from JD Vance at at
very
>> Wait, we're saying why would it be a unique meme that
a lot of cultures gravitate towards evil Johnny Bravo?
Why would it be a unique meme? Why would why would it happen
all over the place? Why is it a thing that reemerges everywhere?
And then you have to merge that with what he I guess said implied
Nick Fentes was like arguing about right to begin with. He basically
disagreed with everything Nick Fuentes said that are unassimilable.
If assimilable if they were not unass unassimilable
right and I'm not saying like literally I'm saying they resist
That seems obviously true. But if you disagree with that then
what is causing anti-semitism all over the place all the
>> Thank you for the opportunity to speak. Um, I'm a Christian
man and I'm just uh confused why that there's this notion that
we uh might have uh owe Israel something or that they're our
greatest ally. Um, I'm just confused why this idea has come around
um considering the fact that not only does their religion not
agree with ours but also openly uh supports the prosecution of
ours. >> Yeah. So
>> now that MAGA on some level it has really rooted itself
in this semi-isolationist very much America first position. Okay,
that's what I said. I was like, "Okay, if you're just going to
say genetically people are neurotic, like overly neurotic and
they'll overreact and that makes them very funny and susceptible
to like memes and and being whipped up into a frenzy on social
media, then okay, that's an
>> And this young very online right one looks at what has
happened in Gazin, I think, correctly sees it as immoral, >> but
two asks, why are we involved here at a time when we're pushing
Europe out on its own? >> Sure. Sure. >> Right. when
we are aggressively insisting that we have no stable alliances
except what is directly in our self-interest at a given moment.
There are ways many many ways to be anti-Israel without being
anti-semitic. But but there is also a way in which the I think
desire among Duke to say that what Israel is doing never can
be connected to anti-semitism breaks apart. And I never quite
know how to talk about this except that I feel like we're all
living through it right now. >> Yeah. Yeah. I mean it's
very difficult. I don't need to put my cards on the table. I'm
I'm I'm, you know, I'm on the left side of the political spectrum
and I've been extremely critical of Israel and especially its
its conduct in the in the war, which I I believe they probably
committed a genocide.
>> Okay.
What how does that translate to your support of Israel? Are you
going to continue to support Israel if they continue to elect
or if they continue to elect right-wing governments that are
willing to perpetuate this? Will you continue to support Israel?
If the answer is yes, then shut the up. You're lying. uh and
and absolutely extreme war crimes, you know, but uh what happened
also was the creation of an enormous amount of free propaganda
for anti-semitic agitators. Um and also why is that a but? That's
an and. Why did he just say but?
Why did you say but? That's an and. But implies that you're about
to say something that cuts against the first part. I'm sorry.
I don't know why that bothers me. Right. He should say, "Well,
it was a genocide. It was clearly a ton of war crimes and it
made a bunch of anti-semitic propaganda for agitators. Shouldn't
be a butt. >> A lot of people becoming curious about US
foreign policy history. You know, there's a certain extent to
which they're grabbing a lot of people who otherwise would be
getting involved in the political process in a really positive
way. They say, "Why is American foreign policy like this? Should
we be doing this? What's the history behind all this? Like why
are these people fighting? Why are they killing each other?"
They get they have legitimate and interesting questions. But
instead, that curiosity, that legitimate curiosity is being picked
up by people who have another motivation here. I I don't think
that Tucker Carlson uh lost much sleep over the Arabs who died
in >> I have no, you know, I'm not defending the war in
any way, but I just have zero sympathy for them or their culture,
a culture where people just don't use toilet paper or forks.
>> And I don't really believe it when he now uh gets very
sentimental about people in Gaza. One of the reasons that I'm
mad about Gaza.
>> Okay, you understand that the United States does not
pay Israel
like that insane an amount of money in dollars, right? You're
a hero.
What is different? Don't look at what's the same. Look at what's
different. How do they give money to Israel? What What privileges
does Israel have? Am I going to see Egyptian F-35s?
Am I going to see Jordanian F-35s?
Am I going to see Saudi F-35s? It's almost like they're a little
different and you're making a comparison that makes no sense.
Very interesting. >> Is because the Israeli position is
everyone who lives in Gaza is a terrorist because of how they
were born, including the women and the children. That's not a
western view. That's an eastern view. That's a non-Christian.
That's totally incompatible with Christianity. So, I hate that
attitude. It's genocidal. >> I think it's highly cynical.
I think when Fuentes
uh expresses some of the most um you know uh spiteful dismissive
attitudes towards human suffering you can imagine on his podcast
on his on his show and then he gets very sentimental about this
issue. >> This is just a straightup genocide. These people
are starving. They're literally dying. It would be formally called
the famine except that Israel will not let any international
personnel inside the strip to assess this to make that declaration.
>> Turkish F-35s are interesting.
The funny thing is is I don't know if if anybody who conceivably
doesn't trust NATO, I don't know if they want F-35s. That's the
funny thing,
right? Oh, apparently also the Saudis just put a bid in for 48
F-35s. So, we'll see. I feel like there's no shot. If there's
any government, I feel like what will happen is the Trump government
might approve that and whatever government comes in next mysteriously
will go nah
nah no thank you >> and you know that is to drag people
in and to think well you know these people have a heart and they're
interested in the same topic as I'm interested. I think it's
highly cynical. I think it's highly cynical. I think one way
you can tell if these views are motivated by
impartial analyses of American foreign policy or much more partial
views about >> Hold on. Um, they're talking about how Fentes
is dumb. Give me a second. Want to answer this. >> Uh,
maybe they get models. Well, I think that's the problem people
have with the F-35s is like a flying supercomput, right? And
people are probably worried that the US is going to have something
in there that will allow them to disable that if those people
ever go against NATO or the West in general. And it's like or
you know hypothetically if you are anti-Semitic, which I believe
basically every Mediterranean state, every Middle Eastern or
Mediterranean state that exists is probably anti-semitic to some
extent. If you believe Israel controls the US, you probably don't
want F-35s if you're worried about having to go after Israel.
to think, well, you know, these people have a heart and they're
interested in the same topic as I'm interested. I think it's
highly cynical. I think it's highly cynical. >> I think
one way you can tell if these views are motivated by
impartial analyses of American foreign policy or much more partial
views about the is whether or not they tend to coexist with unrelated
conspiracies. >> So, in some ways, what I found most telling
was another clip from the the Carlson Fuentes interview.
>> Oh, which one is it going to be? Oh, this is going to
be what? Christian Zionism that Tucker thinks Christian Zionists
are disgusting or will this be about having Jesus?
One of those two, right?
With only fans, it's like um it's like having a Tik Tok. It's
like here's my link tree. Here's my Instagram account. Here's
my Facebook account. Here's my YouTube. And here's my Only Fans.
>> Why would any of this be legal?
>> I think that um well, there's like you indicated, maybe
there's an intelligence benefit to that. Yeah, >> maybe
there's a political benefit to that. I think that >> why
wouldn't you arrest the people who run something like that? >> It
should be if you had a Christian >> Or how about just a
government that cares about its people? I mean, is Iran a bigger
threat or only fans? Iran's not turning my daughters to prostitution.
>> Is it even parse this clip? You have to
>> wait.
Okay.
Is that what we're going to do? We're going to read that into
Oh, really? We're going to read I know where they're going to
go. They're going to say, "Well, the intelligence band is talking
about people. There's a conspiracy about how people run the industry.
Intelligence Ben means industry. They could blackmail people.
They could look it through your webcam. Probably ties into Epstein
somehow. Like that would be the intelligence. I understand how
they'll tie it in.
Man, that makes you look neurotic. I wouldn't even I don't even
know that I'd say I would not bet my mortgage that that's wrong.
Okay. I would not exactly go, "No, no, no. There's no way they
meant that." I wouldn't do that. But man, you gotta
that's a tough one to prove out, right? That's one of those things
where it's like I probably It's like
probably 6040. Think correct. Fentes is saying it's a
Pro uh no 7525 Fentes is saying it's a problem. Maybe even 8020.
But for Tucker to see that and then acknowledge and agree that
it's a problem, like a an ethnically based problem,
I think that's like 40. I think that's on the lower side of 50/50.
So again, I guess that there's a lot of biases that get loaded
in there and I don't know, man, I don't know how to untangle
that.
That's tough. Also, the real Dr. Cube, I'm not saying people
do. That's a conspiracy that people are the only ones invested
in. They run the industry. They've always run the industry. That's
like something people say. I don't know how much of a conspiracy
it is. I think the mind freak guys, the guy who owns, but then
outside of that, I don't know. >> Know that one of the
big anti conspiracies of >> you. Yo Marva dude, thank you
for the gifted sub to forcing young co >> this era is it
in general and maybe the Israeli government in particular is
behind a lot of >> the reason they run the industry I think
is because
they're not Christian
and not only are they not Christian but they're they're against
Christianity and >> oh Fentes ties this into like old stuff
that used to be I think there was a time in medieval Europe that
in like a couple different kingdoms just ended up going to like
assassination work. They're kind of like the mafia in some of
these places. And I think Fentes ties that in that like all of
Europe was Christian. People were devoutly Christian. And so
you couldn't get like Christian assassins. You could basically
you had to get people outside the faith and people were who they
went to. >> The people that were the pioneers of they are
quoted as saying this is like a middle finger to go. >> Connie
West has talked about this. David Duke has talked about this
and and here you have fun Carlson
sort of gesturing at this. Maybe there's an intelligence benefit
to all this we've got out there now. If you had a real Christian
government, we wouldn't allow it, >> And that's where I
think you see something else is happening in the soil here as
opposed to just old school isolationism on American foreign policy.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's every dissatisfaction with the modern
world, every social problem, you relate back to that issue. That's
the explanation for it. It simplifies every single social issue
and it makes a recognizable enemy responsible for it. That's
not new. You know, you have that same thing going back in European
anti-semitism, blaming um every single social problem back to
the I think one of the things that has unnerved me most in the
last few weeks was a tweet from Kevin Roberts, the the head of
the >> Wait, hold on. The real Dr. Cube just asked me something
really funny. I know. Uh wait, wait, wait. How does Fuentes reconcile
how much is tied to
Wait, if you if you compare Christian count's age of consent
to countries of other religions, how does that match up? Just
can we get a quick we get a quick polling of that?
What are you I don't I don't think you know what you're talking
about. I think I think the problem is in a lot of other places
it's actually just not illegal or really against the doors. I
think I think that's a very interesting way you frame that. >> Finish
and and the architect of project 2025
and Robert's got himself in a lot of trouble to talk about it
for for immediately coming in and defending Carlson. But around
the same time >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's talking about
He's obviously talking about the Catholic Church scandal. Yes.
I'm just telling you that like you go to Muslim countries, THAT'S
JUST FINE. Good luck.
Not fine. It but it is Listen, it happens. Okay.
What did Sneo say? The the age of consent is the age you get
married at. >> He had had Jonathan Height, the sort of
critic of the internet, uh at Heritage to talk about >> and
digital addiction and other things. And he sends out this this
tweet. He says, "Thank you on height for reminding everyone at
Heritage yesterday that tech like Leoned Ravinsky and Solomon
Freriedman are profiting to the tune of millions by praying on
America's young men and women. We are proud to be in this fight
with you. It is time to arrest, prosecute, and convict."
Wait,
what? Why are you
How are they going to disagree with this? Oh, I missed them tying
Kevin Robertson. Hold on. This is actually interesting. This
is interesting to see how these people think about it. Okay,
cuz like these guys are two these guys are two people who are
like pretty highly respected intellectuals
in like the liberal space, the left liberal space. Well, at least
Klein is respected in the in the liberal space. Okay, I find
this interesting cuz I don't know. They're they're going to tie
Kevin Robertson is like also he hates Pub. Is that are they going
to try to make that anti-Semitic? They're they're dangerously
close to doing the caricature thing like um
It's actually very concerning to me that you are attacking the
industry. I think that might be a sign of anti-semitism.
I think that's my concern is that what that's what they're leaning
towards and I I just don't want to see that. Okay. For their
own sake, don't do that.
You can't make the immoral thing a sign criticizing an immoral
thing can't be a sign of anti-semitism. Okay? Don't make that
your brand. You don't want to make that your brand. That's a
bad brand. >> To all this we've got out there now, if you
had a real Christian government, we wouldn't allow it. >> Right?
And that's where I think you see something else is happening
in the soil here as opposed to just old school isolationism on
American foreign policy. >> Yeah. I mean, it's every dissatisfaction
with the modern world. Every social problem, you relate back
to that issue. That's the explanation for it. It simplifies every
single social issue and it makes a recognizable enemy responsible
for it. That's not new. You know, you have that same thing going
back in European anti-semitism, blaming um every single social
problem back to the I think one of the things that has unnerved
me most in the last few weeks was a tweet from Kevin Roberts,
the the head of the Heritage Foundation and and the architect
of project 2025. >> And Roberts got himself in a lot of
trouble to talk about it for for immediately coming out and defending
Carlson. But around the same time, he had had Jonathan Height,
the sort of critic of the internet, uh at Heritage to talk about
and digital addiction and other things. And he sends out this
this tweet. He says, "Thank you on height for reminding everyone
at Heritage yesterday the tech." >> Well, is he going to
say that? Is he going to say Tucker's
re-echoing this and that has something to do with Ravinsky is
vaguely Russian now?
Ah, Freriedman. Freriedman, we know like Freriedman would be
an obvious name, >> Moons like Leoned Ravinsky and Solomon
Freriedman are profiting to the tune of millions by praying on
America's young men and women. We are proud to be in this fight
with you. >> I hate to do it. Are we going to we're going
to have to do a quick
Quick, quick, quick. Oh, no way.
Oh, what? Oh, I know this Rinsky guy. I think I know this Rvinsky
guy.
Hold on one second. One second. I think I know about him because
of elixir, but hold on. Not that guy. Who's the other guy? The
other guy is I'm trying to find the Who's the other guy? Solomon
Freriedman. Solomon
Freriedman. Oh, I don't know.
Oh, this is the This is the guy who owns MineGeek. I see. you
didn't convict the sick perverts behind only fans and right and
the key thing about this tweet is you could have chosen to single
out no one or if you're going to sing out only two people there
are a lot of people you might choose like the CEO of only fans
is named Kylie Blair >> but Roberts who is at the center
of establishment Republican politics ahead of their definition
he chooses these two people with very names it was very >> Wait
how do you know Solomon I don't Solomon Rinski is a sorry a Russian
name
he's like from Odessa
he's from Odessa, later immigrated to Chicago. Oh, he is. Never
mind.
I hate the early life check people, but I just wanted to see.
Okay.
Why is wait why is this in here? Who added this? This is so different.
This is so different from most of Wikipedia. Usually like he
was born in this year to parents in the in the year of our Lord
2025 when anti-semitism is becoming mainstream. We just have
he is added here at some point. At some point, somebody just
came along was like, "Hey, I'm going to edit this article. He
is
period." He is.
Can we just get like a category on the side here? We don't even
need the early life check anymore. We could just have a little
category here. There'll be like a a set of flares. Okay. We could
have like a Star of David flare for these people, right? And
then I don't even have to scroll down to early life. It could
just be at the top. We could have like a Star of David flare.
I don't know if anybody's thought about this. Joe, >> very
hard for me not to read this as Robert, whoever's writing for
him >> is pointing towards >> just to know that we're
not like anti anti-ionist. Okay, it could be yellow instead of
blue. It could be yellow just so they know we're not anti-ionist.
We're not attacking Israel. We're just saying, hey, just in case
you're going to do the early life thing >> affinity with
this part of right >> I think you're absolutely right to
pick up on that. I mean, Papy Canon used to do this. What they
used to say about Papy Canon is he always talks about Goldman
Sachs but not Morgan Stanley. And Papan always would say when
he was opposing some uh US foreign policy thing that had some
consensus behind it, he would mention Kissinger, he would mention
Richard Pearl, he would mention those guys. Would he mention
Jean Kurpatre? Would he mention Alexander Hey? No. Some of those
names not important. Um so yeah, continually hammering on that
uh is a big part of their politics is I mean it's the center
of their politics. But it just struck me and this is true for
Roberts and the way he responds to a lot that's happening >> you
might think, oh, [laughter] is this just the intentional side
of the right? This is just the people who are trying to create
big events for the YouTube algorithm and maybe it starts there
or for the X algorithm. Maybe it begins there. But when you see
it jump these lines, I mean you then also the Kevin Roberts response
to the Carlson Fuentes interview which I mean maybe it's worth
watching that too because I think it has some of the same dynamics.
>> My loyalty as a Christian and as an American is to Christ
first and to America always. When it serves the interest of the
United States to cooperate with Israel and other allies, we should
do so with partnerships on security, intelligence, and technology.
But when it doesn't, conservatives should feel no obligation
to reflexively support any foreign government, no matter how
loud the pressure becomes from the globalist class or from their
mouthpieces in Washington. We will always defend our friends
against the slander of bad actors who serve someone else's agenda.
That includes Tucker Carlson, who remains and as I have said
before, always will be a close friend of the Heritage Foundation.
The venomous coalition attacking him are sewing >> Their
attempt to cancel him will fail. >> He's in a bit of hot
water for that now. Yeah, he is. Yeah. Uh but that was his first
instinct. Yeah. Well, I mean he yes, I think that's his first
instinct. He wanted to defend Tucker who I think he views as
extremely important part of the of conservative movement or the
rightwing now and and wants to maintain a relationship with him
obviously, but yeah, you know, the Heritage Foundation is essentially
part of the nervous system of the of of the conservative movement.
It's one of the, you know, important think tanks that comes up
with policy that that supports the work of of of intellectuals
and elites and in the conservative movement. And yeah, watching
that being and and watching the institution seem to break in
that direction was remarkable. Um, and that caused a a firestorm.
He has apologized. He has walked it back. His friend Yor Hazone
flew in from Israel to to to try to to to sort things over. Yeah,
it was a very weird video and and it it struck me as almost coming
from sci-fi. I I was I was so taken back by it. And then he he
falls back on what they all fall back on now is, you know, anti-
cancel culture, anti-wokeness, which means like, okay, there's
no there's no standards anymore. You know, we don't cancel people.
Bro, what? This guy is like openly
the It's like off-putting how openly
I don't want to say he just won't engage at all. He won't He's
not even saying what makes these people He's just like lining
up anti-semites through innuendo only. Literally nothing hardcore
at all. Nothing nothing concrete, nothing
nothing solid. He's just like going to web together. He's working
from Fentes. He's going to work from like Fentes to
like Benjamin Netanyahu. He's gonna be able to paint Benjamin
Netanyahu as an anti-semite at some point. >> But there's
another interesting part of this when he says, "My loyalty as
a Christian and as an Americanist to Christ first and to America
always." One of the things that you see when you begin diving
into the fissures on the right about this >> is for some
time there's been a fairly close embrace between evangelical
Christianity and and Israel and that has in some ways solved
this coalitional problem on the right. And what you hear funday
is doing, what you hear uh these, you know, people coming up
and asking JD Vance questions doing, what you hear in some ways
Tucker doing is really saying that doesn't make any sense. >> And
then the the Christian Zionists who are well Christian Zionists
like what is that? And I can just say for my self I dislike them
more than anybody, you know, because like what because it's Christian
heresy and I'm offended by that as a Christian. I mean, look,
the the attachment of evangelicals to Israel is a particular
current in evangelical Christianity, dispensationalism. Um, it's
one that some argue has very deep roots in American past because
of, you know, of Calvinist uh ideas and and American Christian
Zionism going back to the founders. Um, and there's something
to that, but this emerges really um as a as a mass phenomenon
um in kind of in the 1970s, right? uh where
evangelical Christians are looking what's happening in Israel
as kind of signs of the coming apocalypse. Um and that becomes
extremely popular uh and Israel is befriended is cultivated because
they think it is about to bring about you know the rapture and
so on and so forth. Now it's true I think younger Christians
younger evangelical Christians even I'm not sure how much of
a hold dispensationalism has anymore. It seems to be something
that's like a lot of the things we're discussing of older generations.
So I think that that >> well I mean that's one of those
things where it sounds like this was based on them going well
the apocalypse is coming and then the apocalypse didn't come
so
it seems like it's was kind of a stupid thing to think right
it's a really stupid thing to think >> that appears to
be changing I agree with >> but this goes to what you're
talking about with Roberts he did have to walk this back he's
apologized he said he let Heritage down >> this has led
to a bunch of interesting reporting on what's been going on inside
the Heritage Foundation >> and what >> can they I
just want them to go through. They're never going to go on the
other side of this. And look, I would love to hear their opinion.
What part of Roberts's statement was anti-semitic to you? He
apologized for leaning into harmful stereotypes. Do you think
that's appropriate? You think like him saying a venomous coalition,
you think that was enough to to call him anti-Semitic to get
him to go and apologize and say he needs to step down as the
head of the Heritage Foundation?
the like anti-cancel culture nexus of
says, "Oh, well, this guy said venomous
they're going to fire the head of the anti- cancel culture place
because of a
>> Really, you hear in that reporting is that there's a
big generational split where older staffers were furious at Roberts.
Yeah. >> And are standing up in meetings saying, you know,
the right, you know, Bill Buckley always knew that you had to
to eject the anti-semitums on the right. I see you rolling your
eyes. is it's worth saying that Bill Buckley's um
>> the extent of his war against anti-semitism has been
overstated. Let's put it that way. Um but the younger many of
the younger Heritage Foundation staffers are standing up and
saying, "What did Kevin do wrong here?" Right? If there's not
room for what he said, is there not room for for me? >> And
I think this is getting at just this very big thing which is
and it's what I sort of understood Roberts is doing. >> That
you have a lot of people on the MAGA right trying to skate to
where they think the puck is going. And what they see among their
young, among their staffers, among the people they interact with
on social media is that >> why why do you why do you think
that though? Like why why is he saying that
>> where it's going is around this much more, you know,
I would call it like white nationalist energy. >> Yeah,
I think that's a good read on the situation. Um yeah, you know,
uh Rodrier, a writer who I consider to be on the on the far right,
um but is horrified by everything that's going on. uh he wrote
recently that that a friend of his um in the you know who has
connections to the Republican party in the conservative movement
uh >> hold on Alibaba this is Ezra Klein you can see down
here okay you can tell which one he is he's the other guy >> estimated
that some 30 or 40% of of young staffers were gropers and I would
say to that well the other half are you know maybe don't go to
the last taboo of anti-semitism but definitely don't have any
problem you know throwing slurs around and and and trafficking
and nasty ideas about that um that's my own commentary but yeah
I think that You're absolutely right. I think that there is a
a market generation gap that the younger the younger staff of
the conservative movement are much more open to um Fuentes's
ideas and they've also come up in a situation they've they've
been since their introduction to politics, they've been suffused.
They've been come up in an environment that's filled with this.
They don't know a world before it. It's they're common sense
in a in a way. >> Uh we went a little bit over on the time.
So I'll I'll do like probably 15 more minutes or something. So
yeah, I think that they are >> sorry. I got I overfilled
and I didn't want to do another hour. So I I got overfilled for
the the meter or whatever. The meter got overfilled. So we'll
go >> struggling with the fact that they're probably, you
know, going to have staffing issues. Um and they already >> And
Trump has not criticized like Trump can weigh in on things when
he feels like he called Carlson crazy when Carlson criticized
him for the Iran bombing. Trump has notably not weighed in on
this. Vance has only said he doesn't like the infight. I think
well there there's a lot of reasons for that. I think that the
main reason is look Trump gets a lot of mileage about seeming
out to lunch or or in his own world. The fact of the matter is
he's a successful politician. He understands and he's always
understood from the beginning that this extreme right is a constituency
that he can't really afford to alienate that he has to court.
Uh I think his administration knows that they can't totally distance
him. He's never completely dis >> so his administration
is full of these >> Yes, that's true. >> But maybe
it was not true as true in the first term. >> No. And I
think they're very interested in what this section of the right
has to say and they realize, you know, this is part of our coalition.
We cannot afford to alienate them and attack them. >> So
there have been conservative figures pushing back. >> Ben
Shapiro has particularly, I think, gone to war and has tried
to call this out and really try to play the old at least mythological
William F. Buckley role trying to say, "No, we don't do this.
We don't go to Grober. We don't go to Nicquentes." Like there
there are lines in our movement. >> What have you thought
of Shapiro's response, the reaction to it? >> A few things.
He's getting raped horribly because nobody else nobody else can
even come close. He's just a hypocrite, but nobody can come close
to him. He's got no allies. All of the other popular people on
the right like basically categorically disagree with his disagreements.
And it's been that way. He can say he doesn't agree with a lot
of the things that his contemporaries at the Daily Wire say.
He could say he doesn't agree with Fentes, but he's basically
made his entire nut off of these ideas. He can't really say he's
principally against it when he's earned all of the money in the
world from these ideas.
>> First of all, the thing to remember about one of the
other main figures on the anti-matic right is Candace Owens,
right? Who was, you know, birthed within the Shapiro organization.
So, think about this. >> Well, hired by the Shapiro organization.
>> Hired by the Shapiro cultivated turn into a star. >> Yes.
Part of them trying to skate to where the puff is going, >> right?
To get a younger audience, to get a hipper in the sense of conservatives,
a hipper audience. And and Mark Leavvin at the Republican conference
says, >> "What do you mean we don't cancel
We cancelled David Duke. Donald Trump cancelceled David Duke.
We cancelled Pat Buchanan. We cancelled [laughter] Tom Burch
Society. We cancelled Joseph so we cancel on TV. We cancel stuff
all the damn time. Admirers, Stalin admires, haters, American
haters, church haters. You're damn right. We're going to cancel
them and deplatform them. >> I mean, it's too little too
late. In my view, the opportunity. >> Okay, you [__]
lost. >> Passed. you know, most of the people who saw where
the Republican party was going and didn't like it and were clearsighted
about it, you know, went into the never Trump movement, which
was not politically viable, right? It's a it's a group of people
who I consider to have kind of preserved their honor, but don't
have a mass constituency. The party's not there. These people
stayed with MAGA and everything it represented, the destruction
of all these norms and institutions that would prevent something
like this. Um, and I just am also extremely angry and frustrated
with the pro-Israel and neoonservative right for looking the
other way when it came to the racist takeover of the right. Zoran
Mani perfect example of this. What has happened in the wake of
the giant controversies that exploded about Fontes going on Tucker,
the leaks of the chats, you have major figures on the right who
are trying to redirect the conversation about uh anti-semitism
back to Zoran Mani. are trying to make him the hate figure and
to >> can't we all come together? >> Yes. And and
and so Ben Shapiro says when has Tucker really criticized Zoran
Mandani, right? >> The number of times that Tucker Carlson
has mentioned Zoran Mandani since October 5th on his show is
once. And it was in the context of Marjgery Taylor Green and
Tucker Carlson talking about the appeal of Zoran Mandani. >> And
then Steve Bannon goes he attacks Mark Levvin. He says these
guys are really MAGA and he has a point because they weren't
back then. You know, they weren't with Trump from the beginning.
And then he attacks Mandani. >> Mark Leavin does nothing
but hot air. Mark Levin said run your mouth. What are you doing
in New York City? I tell you what we're doing. We're going to
denaturalize Mandami. So, it directs this this this energy uh
this this this energy of racial hate really um that seeks to
expel a racial other against the safer target, right? Um that
strategy is not working anymore. That ability to keep the coalition
by being like, look, just be as racist as you want, be as hateful
as you want, but it's against it's designated enemies that are
okay.
You know, people ask a rational question. Well, why are are these
people off the table? And then, you know, the answer comes back.
It's like, well, because of Christianity or because Israel represents
Western civilization or some kind of rationalization like that.
And the anti-semmites say that makes no sense to us. And in a
certain sense, yeah, why not? If the world is divided into these
racial groups and and this is the way you are and and and we
practice a politics that's based on that, why make an exception?
I mean, as you say, these guys started as opponents of Trump
in 2016. Shapiro said Trumpism breeds conspiracism. Conspiracism
breeds anti-semitism. Trump is happy to channel support of anti-semites
to his own ends. He Okay, so Ben Shapiro not a dumb guy at that
time. >> If you go back and you read actually a bunch of
what he said back then, uh it's very very very preant. >> The
other thing is what's the super >> opponents of Trump in
2016, Shapiro said Trumpism breeds conspiracism. Conspiracism
breeds anti-semitism. Trump is happy to channel support of anti-semites
to his own. And >> dude, Ben Shapiro is right about everything.
And that's what makes his entire business focus and and his state
of beliefs like so confusing to me. Like Ben Shapiro knew that
this was going to happen. He was he was like, "Oh yeah, obviously
this is like a problem. Obviously I don't support Trump for these
reasons." And then he was just like, "I can make a huge buck
off of Trump. Let's go. I'm I'm locked in, guys. I'm locked in."
>> He Okay, so Ben Shapiro not a dumb guy at that time.
If you go back and you read actually a bunch of what he said
back then, uh it's very very preient. The other thing is what's
the superpower they're going to suddenly discover that they're
going to do that? >> Are they are they not going to have
any commentary on how Ben Shapiro has made millions? Probably
possibly more than just tens, possibly like nine figures. Very
possibly since 2016, 2017 since he founded the Daily Wire. I
think you could probably get up there. He's got to be maybe it's
starting to go back down now with some of their bad investments
and content and stuff. Maybe it's now it's back in the tens of
millions, but I think at some point he probably could have gotten
out with nearly nearly
uh maybe not. nine figures probably pushing it but probably comfortable
20 30 40 $50 million net worth right and he made it all off of
Trump all off of
and then he's going to sit here and say oh I can't believe there's
anti-semitism out here now you guys you guys have changed so
much >> that they couldn't stop Donald Trump they couldn't
stop Donald Trump they tried many of them tried Ben Shapiro wasn't
an opponent of Donald Trump Lavin was an opponent of Donald Trump
so they're going to finally discover some new secret weapon >> 24
I don't know where Levvin was but there was clearly an effort
from Shapir and others to make Dantis the future Sure. Sure.
And yeah, so I don't understand where they suddenly think they're
going to they're going to find the weapons or the army that's
going to support them in this. >> Well, this is what I
think is is frightening when you look at their situation kind
of coldly. Their kind of last best hope is that they don't believe
Trump himself is an anti-semite. Their last hope is Trump himself.
And I mean, they'll say that, but when I on the show, he was
more or less saying that. But they're all much more afraid of
what's coming next of JD Vance in particular, where I think the
view many Republicans hold is that Vance is quietly functionally
where Carlson is that Vance is Ger Jason, let's call it. >> Yeah,
I think that's right. And there is still an 09 Republican party.
>> That's not right. No, that's not right. No, that's not
right. No, that's not right. Okay, that's not right at all.
Hilariously incorrect. JD Vance has no principles or beliefs.
What are we talking about? >> Some degree, you know, Ted
Cruz have been coming out. >> If you sit there with someone
who says Adolf was very, very cool
and that their mission is to combat and defeat global
and you say nothing, then you are a coward and you are complicit
in that >> Lindsey Graham. But I just want to make it really
clear. I'm in the sucks wing of their Republican party.
>> What is this? I don't know. Anyway, >> but it
is the older Republican party, >> right? I think that they've,
you know, >> honestly I think I'm just thanking God that
they didn't have like two or three more of those clips cuz I
swear to God I would start I'd actually I'm straight up like
two seconds away from joining the other side. Whatever side those
guys are on, all of those guys who spoke at that conference,
that's the wrong side. I don't know if it makes Fentes the right
side, but all the people that whatever side that is, I would
never be on that side. Okay,
I'm sorry. I think we all can feel that. All right. Doesn't mean
Fentes is the right side, but that is the wrong side for sure.
>> With the devil in a certain way and and now they're
they're they're paying for the consequences. Now, another way
to read this, obviously, it's all very scary and these are bad
things and the transformation of the Republican party into this
stuff is not good. It wasn't great before in my opinion, but
now it's really something else. The other thing is it's like
this might be a politics that ends up when it's exposed to the
public being too weird and too fringe. It has some mass constituency.
Uh it will it do well in a primary? Yeah, maybe. Probably. Will
it do well with the rest of the public? I don't know. >> Well,
it's done well in primaries before. I think this actually gets
to something important. So, your your book um is very much about
Pat Buchanan and and earlier strains of this. For those who didn't
grow up in the politics of the 1980s, 1990s or didn't write a
bestselling book on it as you did. >> Who's Patan? Patan
is a major figure in the conservative movement. He was a member
of the Nixon administration. He kind of represented the ideological
conservatives like the Buckley conservatives, the National Review
crowd within the Nixon administration. He then went on to be
a very important syndicated colonist col columnist appear on
TV. He was a communications director for some time in um the
Reagan administration. Um important loud voice on the right.
He ran a few primary campaigns. One in 1992 which my book focuses
on um which wounded George W. Bush's candies. So there was kind
of a constituency for his type of politics. He is also probably
the person who expressed anti-semitic views in public the most
notable anti-semite in American politics for a very long time.
>> I always think this clip of Trump talking about Buchanan
is worth >> How about Pat Buchanan? What do you think of
that? I think the funny thing about Pat Buchanan is I can believe
that he's anti-semitic. But when I hear about his anti-semitism,
it's like somebody recalling a quote that they heard from somebody
recalling what Pat can It's like they're recalling what someone
said about what someone else said. Papy Cannon said. I rarely
see a quote that is just Papy Cannon on TV being anti-semitic.
Actually, I've never seen that. So I I'm not saying like that's
wrong or that he was not anti-semitic,
but I've never seen him being openly anti-semitic in a clip.
It's always people going, "Yeah, he's anti-mitic cuz he said
this. He was anti-Semitic cuz he said that. He was anti-semitic
cuz he believed this." And it's like, can I get that in his words
ever?
Seems pretty >> That now he he seems to be the guy you'd
have to battle. >> Well, that's true. He's anti-Semitic.
He's anti-black. He obviously has been having a love affair with
Adolf in some form. And I just can't imagine this guy. >> I
don't want you to hold back. Give me how you feel now. I mean,
you know,
I can't imagine, you know, that Pat that is going to be very
seriously taken as a >> So, that's an earlier Trump incarnation
flirting with the third party run for >> We often talk
about the way Trump has been very consistent on certain things
like trade since the 80s, but not on >> You know, there
was a man Pat Buchanan, a good guy, conservative guy. And you
know, it's not that weird, you know, Pat Buchanan. Look at that.
Good. Good guy. Wow. Young people, they know Pat Buchanan, right?
We know Pat Buchanan. >> He came in second in the New Hampshire
primary. And for 45 years, he made an unbelievable career of
it. He was a hot item. He was on every show. And it's been interesting
watching so many of these figures, Nick Wendy being one of them,
but not by any means alone of them, really rehabilitate Patan.
>> I think the Republican party surprised itself on not
going down Buchanan's lane. It went down another lane instead.
George HW Bush and then George W. Bush. >> But it seems
like now Buchananism is >> That's the thesis of all the
work I've been doing for the past decade in my book. Yes, I think
that's true. And actually, it was interesting at the beginning
of this presidency. I thought, "Oh man, I got something a little
bit wrong. It's Pat Buchanan plus you got to be nice to Israel,
right?" So they're like, "Okay, we can be the trade stuff, the
immigration stuff, that, but we're going to keep in place in
order to keep the coalition together, you know, this reflexive
support of Israel, um, you know, partly to do with with Republicans,
partly to do with with Christian evangelicals." And then when
this explodes, I was like, "Oh, well, I guess that that never
fully went away and it wasn't totally submerged and this coalition
wasn't that stable." >> Well, also it gets to this point
that Buchananism has an internal logic. Yeah. And when you embrace
it, it becomes hard to embrace 80% of his logic, but not 100%
of his logic, >> you know. So there's this book Buchanan
wrote years ago called The Death of the West. Uh JD Vans said
it is the first political book you ever read. How do you describe
the death of the west thesis and how it relates to modern Republican
party politics? >> It basically describes a world where
the white race is submerged by the invasion of brown peoples
and uh that needs to be prevented by any means necessary essentially.
It's a it's a it's a work of of um polite uh white nationalism.
>> And there's a tremendous amount of fertility rates in
I mean, even in the first Trump term reading it, it was striking
to me how much the modern right had fully >> absorbed this
book by this guy who was, you know, pushed out to the margins,
it seemed to be for >> Oh, by the way, that guy uh that
guy will never hop in VC. That guy is terrified.
That guy will never hop in VC >> a long time, right? >> But
I mean, now I think you're going to >> I'm pretty sure
that's the like, if I'm not mistaken name, is that not like the
number one chaser who oils food shops?
I could have sween told me this person's name once. I think that's
like the food chops oil spiler who
like constantly writes fanfic with her and Destiny. I
>> pick a founding text for MAGA. You know, people talk
about all kinds of different, you know, weird thinkers, but death
of the West might be canon feels to me like a >> No, no,
no, no. SFO is like not the primary chaser >> error center
of the cannon. >> Yeah. I mean, look, critics of the right
have often said there was a racial subtext to Western civilization
in in the in the way Buchanan use it. It's not a subtext. It's
it's what Western civilization means. It means white people.
It doesn't mean Homer and Dante and Plato and so forth are ideas.
It means a certain racial stock that makes up Western people.
And basically the division on the right right now is uh are just
part of that western white people. Um this is like the weirdest
conversation where like they don't prove anything out. They just
take a whole bunch of things for granted. They never ever make
any attempt to like start from some base, right? Ever. Uh,
I'm just looking for anybody. Is anybody Someone flew in from
Israel to correct an American's view on Israel. And y'all want
to present that without any thought about how it looks at like
an example of the problem?
I I thought it was crazy how they they unpacked nothing here.
Just zero unpacking of any any ideas. Nothing. They didn't really
contend with any of the things the other people were saying.
They just go they they're anti- they're anti-semitic. They're
anti-semitic. All these ideas are anti-semitic. I I kind of wish
they would talk about stuff and nobody's really calling them
out. It's either it's either people saying this is good or it's
like Roy Bur saying America versus inevitable.
>> I guess one thing that part of this conversation that
reflects is how much of this is all the internet and attentional
dynamics and as such we are moving into this structurally and
there aren't very good political answers to it. I mean, you you've
had this line that one could even say that the internet itself
is anti-semitic, which also was a kind of provocative line, but
but I'm curious because you've been writing more. You gave a
speech at Chicago where you're talking about the sort of modern
version of fascism as a response to the way the internet has
destabilized the way we communicate and the sort of political
sphere. >> How much do you see what we're in as a structural
feature of the medium on which politics now primarily certainly
political communication primarily takes place? Like what follows
from an analysis like that? Well, I mean the the the comment
about the internet being structurally anti-semitic, very speculative
theory of mine that I I cannot defend right now. But um yeah,
obviously the chain >> dude this guy
I don't know why Ezra would interview this guy as like the the
this is like his answer to
everything. Why would he Why would he interview this guy? This
looks so weird. I haven't I haven't seen this guy justify a single
belief he has. It's very bizarre to me where somebody comes on
and says this is anti-semitic. This guy was anti-semitic. all
of his he doesn't prove anything out, right? He doesn't he doesn't
actually say or prove anything. And I understand like I can understand
dog whistling. I can understand trying to like wink and nod and
I can I can give you like probabilities on that. I can tell you
what I think it is and what I think you prove it is. I can handle
that. But they don't do anything. They just say this is anti-Semitic.
That was anti-Semitic. This was anti-Semitic. That was anti-Semitic.
Yeah. And then I get comments like this from love love the pie
and it's like dude people are really tired of whatever this is.
Whatever this is this like totally lazy handling of anti-semitism.
You guys actually have to do some work now. Whatever cultural
luster you had when you use this word and everybody fled. It's
gone. You need to do some work. Don't don't just show up and
go anti-semitism. Like it's a magic spell to make everybody who
disagrees with you disappear. That's not the way this works anymore.
Come with some facts. come with some actual things that you can
back up. Say some that can be understood by somebody who doesn't
share your exact worldview. Please change in the way people consume
media creates the possibility for new communities to form, right?
People who would generally be cranks and uh fringe people with
a few audience members find find mass audiences, right? So there
is there's a cone of that. There's also the the fact that the
internet um makes it's almost like the birth of cities is the
way I think about it. It's almost like urbanization. It creates
an enormous amount of what you might call sanitary problems.
Like it creates enormous amount of waste, pollution, and stuff
like this. And there we haven't come to a way of being like,
okay, well, we're going to disc decide how we we govern this
new city. It's very interesting though, you know, like where
where anti like where do people get into this stuff? You know,
you mentioned, right? It comes from this really seedy underbelly
of the internet, the bulletin boards or message boards, han 4chan,
etc. Like that. It comes from a community that you know consumes
very edgy sometimes illicit. It came from the same you know underbelly
the sewage of the internet from the gutter. It is you know the
favorite ideology of the very people who you know sometimes have
addictive relationships to those things um and feel disempower
[laughter] okay this is interesting.
This this is a totally failed strategy by the way. You can't
shame people out of
uh like grievance politics. You can't shame people out of grievance
politics.
You cannot do it. This is a totally failed tactic. You are a
for attempting to employ this. You You're like an incel. Like
you don't like women. Uh have you thought about the fact that
you're like a disgusting virgin ugly loser who will never be
loved by anybody? Yeah, THAT'S THE GENERAL IDEA, BUDDY. That's
the general idea. That's literally why we're here. You cannot
shame me out of the thing that is admitted by the tag I use.
Shut up. >> Entirely disempowered to detach themselves
from it. uh feel like they have no lives or future. The internet
is their only life and future. But it also presents itself as
a politics that would solve those problems. You know, all of
the things that happened because of modernization or the creation
of this new of these new structures. We we have the answer to
to um to to to fix them all. Um it's interesting, you know, Fuentes
openly says like I'm one of those guys, right? He's like, I'm
kind of a loser and incel, you know, there's no women in my life,
etc., etc. But the way he does that and the way he attracts an
audience and the way he entertains his audience is when he has
um their questions come on. He sadistically attacks them, right?
>> What do you mean? What do I think? That's your question.
So Byron Donald, some like black Republican benchwarmer, gets
up at the RJC and says, "I love Israel. I support immigration."
You say, "What do you think about that? What do you think I think
about that?" That's your question. The show is like, "We hate
immigration. We're against Israel." Hey, so this guy says he
likes immigration in Israel. What do you think about that? That's
your question. What do I think about that? What do you think
I think about that, you idiot? Because essentially like that's
>> a black guy said he disagrees with you. What do you
think about that? Is that the guy who said it was black this
time? Have you thought about how you go after a black guy for
being a Zionist? Have you thought Huh? I just want to hear Well,
it's like all my favorite things in one.
It's about a certain >> Have you Have you thought about
jumping off a roof, buddy? >> Type of powerlessness that
comes to express itself in sadism. There's a degree of self-loathing
among these people that can't also be uh discounted. There's
a degree to which they
dude this guy I legitimately I gave every bit of charity I could
to this interview. I was like I'll I'll actually sit here. I'll
listen. I'll try to understand. This was awful. This was zero
insult provided or sorry insult zero insight provided. This was
bad. Okay. This was rough.
A rough interview. have accepted their position as being kind
of outside of society, as being unrepresented, and they just
want to burn it all down. I think I have this theory about Twitter.
Yeah. Which is >> uh I feel like really really about my
terrible predicament of the fact that I can't make money, the
fact that I can't get women and and you know that makes me want
to kill myself and
and so I'm going to I'm going to say edgy things on the internet
and then somebody comes along, they're like, "You're ugly. You're
ugly." It's like, yeah, that's a part of the label of incel.
you you have no future. Yeah, it's like all things they accepted.
What I don't know why are you trying to insult somebody who's
like already integrated all of those negative things about themselves.
I it doesn't make any sense >> is that whichever political
coalition is in control of it at a given moment is going to pay
dearly for that. >> So I think that you know the left sort
of had the wheel on Twitter you know around 2020 and by 2024
a lot of the positions that got taken for that reason a lot of
the culture that emerged on it ended up >> okay I think
this has been kind of I don't even care to watch the ending.
Here's the time stamp. I'm gonna go. I love you guys. We almost
made it to the end. I'm just gonna Well, hold on. Give me two
seconds. I'll say I might not go. Let me I'll hit play. Give
me a second. I might watch the end. Just give me two >> Proving
a profound political loser. And I [snorts] remember people being
terrified on the left when Elon Musk bought it. But what I see
is the right is becoming Twitter poisoned. X poison. >> And
you know that guy in a basement making fun of his followers claiming
to be an incel politics,
>> It's very I mean I've spent the last week like immersed
in prep for this and You begin to think it's the world. >> And
then you like look up and you kind of shake your head and you
remember it's >> And most people don't want this and have
no And the right seems so hooked in to its own attentional drugs
at the moment. >> And JD Vance seems to want to be the
future of the right is very very very hooked in to its weird
subculture. He said that himself
>> that I wonder if I mean one thing you hear Shapiro keep
trying to say to like this is going to be a loser and I don't
think it's specifically the anti-semitism of that too. But the
whole
>> I got to go. Uh, I'll talk to you guys